cette crise sanitaire qui mute et qui
évoluent dans des conditions inquiétante
une fois encore nous devons faire face
prendre en toute lucidité les décisions
que la situation impose la gravité de
cette troisième vague
l'impact de ces décisions sur nos
concitoyens qui font face courageusement
et depuis des mois à cette pandémie
mondiale commande que les représentants
de la nation en débattent et s'exprime
par un vote solennel dans le cadre fixé
par l'article 50-1 la constitution ces
mesures nouvelles sont donc nécessaires
pour protéger la vie et la santé de
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
particulièrement les plus fragiles elles
sont nécessaires pour nous permettre de
franchir un cap
espérons le un dernier cap dans la
perspective du déploiement massif de la
vaccination et d'un retour à une vie
normale
oui la troisième vague est là et elle
nous frappe durement
nous constatons depuis la mi mars
un emballement de l'épidémie en deux
semaines le nombre de cas a augmenté de
55 % et s'élève aujourd'hui à environ 38
milles par jour
[Musique]
l'épidémie progresse vite et elle
progresse partout cette accélération est
dû vous le savez mesdames et messieurs
les députés à la progression du baril y
en a peu vu en fin d'année dernière
grande bretagne nous savons depuis
plusieurs mois qu'il est plus contagieux
nous savons depuis plus récemment nous
savons depuis plus récemment kid est
aussi plus dangereux
à la lumière des dernières études
scientifiques comme je le constate à 5
une de mes visites dans les hôpitaux le
virus frappe des patients plus jeunes et
en plus grande proportion sans facteurs
de risque liés à des comorbidités ce
phénomène est évidemment pas propre à la
france
depuis la mi mars le nombre de cas
quotidiens a triplé en allemagne il a
augmenté de 70% en belgique et de 40%
pire cette reprise épidémique est
d'autant plus préoccupante qu'elle
survient à un moment où notre système de
santé est déjà mis un lourde
contribution et ce depuis longtemps avec
plus de cinq mille malades de l'aco vide
hospitalisés en réanimation
le pic de la deuxième vague est déjà
dépassé si nous sommes encore en deçà du
niveau atteint au printemps 2020 nous
devons agir vite en amplifiant fortement
les dispositions déjà en vigueur
face à ce niveau virus nous avons
rapidement réagi en prenant ces derniers
mois et ces dernières semaines plusieurs
mesures fortes maintient depuis fin
octobre de la fermeture de nombreuses
activités établissements recevant du
public mesures fortes critiqué à
l'époque couvre-feu national depuis la
mi décembre
mesurant forcément dans près de 20
départements couvrant près d'un tiers de
la population depuis le 20 mars dernier
ces décisions ne sont jamais faciles
elles ne sont jamais sain elles
obéissent à plusieurs exigences
rechercher le meilleur équilibre
possible entre protection et contraintes
agir ni trop tôt ni trop tard
en s'adaptant en temps réel
aux évolutions de l'épidémie mais aussi
mais aussi aux différences de situations
territoriales notamment en début de
vagues épidémiques
enfin rappelé toujours et encore les
consignes de prudence en faisant appel à
l'esprit de vigilance et de
responsabilité de chacune et de chacun
c'est par la conciliation de ces
différents principes d'action que nous
sommes parvenus depuis maintenant quatre
mois à maintenir la situation sous
contrôle
mais aujourd'hui les faits sont là le
variant britannique poursuit son
accélération
nous devons nous aussi accéléré c'est à
dire prendre des mesures renforcées si
nous voulons casser la spirale
épidémique qui s'est enclenchée depuis
quelques semaines c'est pourquoi nous
avons décidé sous l'autorité du
président de la république d'étendre à
tout le territoire métropolitain
les mesures qui s'appliquait déjà dans
les dix-neuf départements les plus
touchés par l'épidémie
ces nouvelles mesures s'appliqueront à
compter de dimanche matin et pour quatre
semaines jusqu'au 3 mai ce choix d'agir
à l'échelle nationale s'explique par le
fait que depuis une dizaine de jours
l'épidémie s'est propagée dans la quasi
totalité du territoire national
sur les 96 départements métropolitains
92 connaissent une accélération de la
circulation virale avec des rythmes
parfois spectaculaires supérieure à 20%
sur une semaine dans la moitié des
départements et à plus de 40 %
d'augmentation dans une vingtaine
d'entre eux dans une telle situation il
convient d'agir fortement rapide
et partout selon les mêmes règles et les
mêmes calendrier nous feront cependant
une exception pour les territoires et
départements d'outre-mer dans la
situation sanitaire n'est évidemment pas
la même qu'en métropole
ni même que d'un territoire à l'autre
compte tenu de leur éloignement
géographique nous continuerons donc
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
leur appliquer des règles spécifiques et
qui s'adapte en fonction des évolutions
épidémie propres à chacun d'entre eux
comme l'a indiqué hier le président de
la république les règles qui
s'appliqueront à compter de dimanche
matin au territoire national seront
fondamentalement les mêmes que celles
que nous avons mis en place depuis le 20
mars dernier dans les dix-neuf
départements soumis à des mesures
renforcées le couvre-feu sera maintenu à
partir de 19h les conditions d'ouverture
ou de fermeture de commerces obéiront
aux mêmes critères et conditions le
télétravail sera systématisé quatre
jours par semaine minimum pour tous les
emplois publics et privés où cela est
possible les motifs de sorties et de
déplacement seront encadrés selon les
mêmes termes
il restera possible de se déplacer de se
promener de faire du sport sans
limitation de durée dans un rayon de 10
km autour de chez soi en revanche les
rassemblements ou regroupement de plus
de 6 personnes resteront interdits enfin
une attestation président précisant le
motif du déplacement sera exigée au delà
des 10 km et après la fin du prochain
week-end de pâques les déplacements
inter régionaux seront restreints à
quelques motifs impérieux ces motifs
incluront évidemment les déplacements
professionnels mais aussi se lier un
motif familial comme par exemple
accompagné ou aller cherche
et un enfant chez un parent un grand
parent ou un proche
l'enjeu des prochaines semaines ne se
limitera pas à l'édiction de nouvelles
règles il s'agira surtout de permettre
leur bonne appropriation par nos
concitoyens et bien sûr de veiller à
leur bonne application
si l'immense majorité
si l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
spontanément les règles en vigueur
une minorité d'entre eux s'y refuse
à ce titre je veux devant vous condamner
sans réserve
l'irresponsabilité dont font montre
certains se croyant sans doute
invincible aux ravages de la maladie qui
pourtant nous démontre chaque jour le
contraire
ces comportements il s'agit ces
rassemblements festifs du non respect du
couvre-feu ou du refus du port du masque
nous devons les prévenir et les
sanctionner
j'ai demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
d' accroître le nombre de policiers et
de gendarmes affectés à cette tâche
nous veillerons notamment à ce que
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de six personnes sur la voie
publique soit respectée la consommation
d'alcool sur l'espace public sera
interdite sur arrêté préfectoral est en
lien étroit avec les maires l'accès à
certains sites propices à des
rassemblements un extérieur comme les
quais berges place pourra être interdits
en fonction des circonstances locales
il sera enfin demandé au parquet de
poursuivre systématiquement les hauteurs
de récidive portant sur l'organisation
d'évènements clandestins susceptibles de
mettre en danger la vie d'autrui
mais ces comportements mais ces
comportements mesdames et messieurs les
députés ne doivent pas masquer la
résilience et la haute conscience
citoyenne de l'immense majorité des
français partout sur le territoire qui
sans doute brasles s'impatient cherchent
légitimement à comprends mais qui se
montre respectueux des règles c'est à
dire finalement respectueux des autres
la forte accélération du virus nous
conduit également à fermer des
établissements scolaires les crèches et
les activités périscolaires et
extrascolaires
nous avons tout fait pour retarder au
maximum cette décision et je sais et je
sais qu'il existait un très large
consensus sur tous les bancs en faveur
du maintien de l'accueil de tous les
enfants dans les établissements
scolaires nous sommes le pays d'europe
qui a le moins fermer ses écoles depuis
le début de l'épidémie
je vous rappelle qu'à nanan elles ont
été fermés moins de dix semaines en
france contre 24 en allemagne 26 au
royaume uni et 32 en italie je crois que
nous pouvons en être fiers
essai et c'est pour cette raison et
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
toujours considéré et que je vous ai
toujours dit que s'il fallait un jour
utiliser ce levier
nous devrions le faire annuler team
recours et dans des conditions qui en
réduisent au maximum l'impact pour nos
enfants
mais force est de constater que les
écoles les collèges et les lycées ne
sont pas épargnée par l'épidémie
depuis deux semaines le taux d'incidence
augmente plus vite chez les enfants et
les adolescents que dans la population
générale avec pour conséquences des
fermetures de classes et d'écoles chaque
jour plus nombreuses c'est pourquoi les
établissements scolaires seront fermés
pendant trois semaines anne optimisant
and optimisant la période des vacances
de printemps pour que les conséquences
sur les enfants soit le ministre y
veille
les moins pénalisante possible
concrètement la semaine prochaine où il
n'y aura que quatre jours d'école en
raison du lundi de pâques tous les
établissements scolaires assureront leur
enseignement à distance
cela concernera également les lycées
professionnels et des apprentis qui
suivront le même régime que les autres
lycéens au cours des deux semaines
suivantes
du 12 au 25 avril tous les élèves de
toutes les zones académiques seront en
vacances dit printemps cela implique une
modification du calendrier des vacances
devrait s'étaler selon les zones du 12
avril au 7 mai je mesure
mesdames et messieurs les députés tout à
fait d'impact de ces décisions sur la
vie de nombreuses familles mais aussi
dans l'organisation des entreprises
mais c'est le moyen d'atteindre notre
objectif de pouvoir agir sur la
contamination en milieu scolaire avec
l'impact le plus limité possible sur
l'année scolaire de nos enfants
nous savons que ces choix peuvent aussi
être source de difficultés pour les
familles modestes dans les enfants
n'iront plus à la cantine ou ne pourront
plus bénéficier de petits déjeuners
gratuits dans les écoles
rép pourrais tu +1 ce titre nous serons
à leurs côtés pour les aider à passer
cette période et des modalités de cet
accompagnement adaptés seront précisées
dans les prochains jours comme lors du
premier confinement un dispositif
d'accueil des enfants des personnels
prioritaires sera organisée dès la
semaine prochaine en lien avec
l'éducation nationale et les
collectivités locales
il en ira de même pour les crèches ils
seront fermés au cours des trois
prochaines semaines tout en étant
mobilisé également sur l'accueil des
enfants des personnels prioritaires dans
la liste complète sera précisée demain
les salariés qui seront contraints de
garder leurs enfants à d'homicide
faute d'autres solutions bénéficieront
du dispositif d'activité partielle qui
s'appliquait déjà lors du premier
confinement ils versent suffira de se
signaler auprès de leur employeur qui
prendra en charge la procédure de
déclaration auprès des services de
l'état pour les élèves de l'enseignement
supérieur les règles en vigueur qui vous
le savez prévoit un enseignement
essentiellement en distance yale ces
règles seront maintenus sans remettre en
cause la possibilité donnée récemment
aux étudiants de pouvoir revenir une
journée par semaine
en présentiel dans des conditions
strictes les concours prévus au cours
des quatre prochaines semaines seront
maintenus et leurs conditions
d'organisation adaptée à la situation
les examens qui ne peuvent se faire un
distanti elles seront en revanche
reporté autant que possible sur le mois
de mai ces nouvelles mesures auront
inévitablement des conséquences sociales
et économiques
je sais la difficulté dans laquelle sont
nos entreprises fermées ou contraints de
fonctionner au ralenti et ce depuis de
longs mois
je sais qu'aux difficultés économiques
s'ajoutent souvent la détresse et le
désarroi de professionnels qui n'ont
qu'une envie exercer leur métier
reprendre leurs activités
je veux dire mon attention à toutes ces
femmes et ces hommes dirigeants
d'entreprises salariés sous traitants
travailleurs indépendants et leur dire
leur assurer la solidarité de la nation
l'état l'état et je crois que c'est une
autre de nos fiertés
mesdames et messieurs les députés a été
au rendez vous de l'accompagnement
économique et social de ces acteurs il
le restera comme il continuera à assurer
la continuité des services publics
nous maintiendrons tous nos dispositifs
en place aussi longtemps que durera la
crise
si nous ne le faisions pas nous
réduirions à néant des mois de soutien
massif et efficace
au delà nous complétons ces mesures pour
mieux tenir compte de certaines
situations
je pense notamment celles des commerces
particulièrement ceux fermés depuis
février dans les grands centres
commerciaux ou encore ceux qui ont
accumulé des stocks importants du fait
des périodes de fermeture
je pense également aux entreprises de
plus grande taille
affecté par de longs mois de crise c'est
le sens
de l'aide exceptionnelle pour la prise
en charge des coûts fixes qui a été mise
en place depuis hier ayant mesdames et
messieurs les députés l'humilité de
reconnaître que nous ne savons pas tout
tout simplement
tout simplement parce que nous faisons
face un risque nouveau sony ge dans nul
ne peut dire avec certitude comment et
les susceptible d'évoluer pour autant un
élément nouveau est venu radicalement
modifié la donne la campagne de
vaccination
la campagne de vaccination progresse et
s'amplifie tous les jours nous avons là
une plaie de penser que nous avançons
petit lot à la voix
une possible sortie de crise plus de 8
millions de nos concitoyens sont
désormais vaccinés dans 2,8 avec les
deux d'or l'objectif du gouvernement
doit être ici réaffirmer 10 millions de
vaccinés ni avril 20 millions mi mai et
30 le million mi juin en veillant à ce
que la commission européenne fasse
respecter les obligations des
industriels
quant au calendrier de livraison des
doses nous serons donc au rendez-vous et
même très au delà des objectifs que
j'avais ici même énoncé devant vous le
17 décembre dernier lors du débat
organisé sur la stratégie vaccinale
reportez vous à ces propos j'avais
annoncé la vaccination de 15 millions de
personnes d'ici la fin du premier
semestre
nous serons très largement en avance
tout le monde tout le monde est sur le
pont vous le savez dans vos territoires
pour que nous puissions vacciner sans
relâche
nous vaccinons aujourd'hui un rythme qui
s'accélère depuis déjà trois semaines
ce rythme est plus élevé que celui de
nos voisins allemands italiens ou
espagnols
c'est la vérité surtout surtout de vous
nous sommes clairement bien positionné
pour la vaccination des personnes n'est
plus vulnérables face à la maladie
nous vaccinons un flux tendu toutes les
deux sont administrées au fur et à
mesure de leur arrivée
cette vaccination s'opère sous
l'autorité du ministre de la santé selon
deux circuits complémentaires premier
circuit les centres de vaccination mis
en place par les mairies les
établissements hospitaliers ou encore
les professionnels de vide
nous en comptons plus de 1700
aujourd'hui et d'autres ouvriront encore
dans les prochaines semaines opéré
notamment par les pompiers ou
l'assurance maladie et qui seront
configurés pour pouvoir accueillir
jusqu'à 1000 à 2000 patients par jour
que tous ces acteurs reçoivent ici la
gratitude du gouvernement et j'en suis
sûr de l'assemblée nationale
deuxième circuit les professionnels de
villes qui sont mobilisées en grand
nombre
plus de cinquante mille médecins et
20000 officines de pharmacie se sont
engagés dans la vaccination en un mois
ils ont administré près de 1 million 700
mille doses aux patients éligibles à
compter de la semaine prochaine
vingt-cinq mid premier infirmiers se
lanceront aussi dans la vaccination
toujours la semaine prochaine près d'un
million 400 mille doses supplémentaires
seront utilisables sur le terrain suivi
de trois millions de doses
supplémentaires
en avril et 3,6 millions en mai le mois
d'avril verra aussi arriver vous le
savez un nouveau vaccin celui de johnson
& johnson qui a la particularité de ne
nécessiter qu'une seule dose
ce sont plus de 500 mille doses qui sont
ainsi attendus fin avril puis 2 millions
en mai comme le chef de l'état l'a
annoncé hier
nous pourrons donc lancé dans les
prochaines semaines la vaccination à de
nouvelles tranches d'âge le 15 avril
pour les personnes âgées de 60 à 62 ans
le 15 mai pour les personnes âgées de 50
à 59 ans le 15 juin
pour tous les autres l'espoir que
représente cette campagne de vaccination
nous permet de regarder l'avenir avec
lucidité mais avec confiance et
optimisme
elle s'accompagnera du maintien et de
l'intensification de l'indispensable
stratégie tester alerte et protégés nous
travaillons également en lien avec tous
les secteurs concernés à la réouverture
prochaine des lieux et activités
aujourd'hui fermé cette réouverture
interviendra lorsque les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies et le
gouvernement présentera cette stratégie
de réouverture devant le parlement le
moment venu nous devrons également nous
prononcer sur les conditions
d'organisation des élections régionales
et départementales prévues les 13 et 20
juin prochains
ces élections ont déjà été reportés pour
cause de covin comme je lai déjà indiqué
et comme je le redis ce matin devant la
représentation nationale
seules des raisons sanitaires impérieuse
de nature à compromettre l'organisation
de la campagne ou du scrutin pourrait
justifier un nouveau report en
application de la loi du 22
vrillé dernier le conseil scientifique a
rendu sur ce sujet un avis lundi
j'observe avec vous que cet avis
particulièrement balancer ne préconise
pas clairement et explicitement un
report des élections
j'ajoute j'ajoute que les décisions dont
nous débattons ce matin y compris celles
relatives à l'accélération de la
vaccination devrait avoir pour effet
d'améliorer la situation sanitaire à
l'échéance du mois de juin le conseil
scientifique formule cependant des
recommandations précises quant aux
conditions de l'organisation et de la
tenue de ces élections tandis que les
mesures nouvelles qui entreront en week
en vigueur ce week-end et pour quatre
semaines pourrait avoir un effet sur le
déroulement de la campagne nous devons
donc nous assurer que l'ensemble de ces
conditions pourront bien être
satisfaites auront bien être satisfaite
pour maintenir le calendrier telles que
la loi l'a prévue scénario qui constitue
pour le gouvernement
l'hypothèse de base à cet effet à cet
effet je vais engager sans délai une
consultation des partis politiques
représentés au parlement parce qu'ils
concourent à l'expression du suffrage et
des associations d'élus locaux notamment
les maires chargé de l'organisation
matérielle des opérations de vote
un débat fondé sur l'article 51 de la
constitution sera organisé au parlement
sur la base de l'ensemble de ces
éléments
tel est le sens du rapport que je vous
remettra est aujourd'hui un application
de la loi du 22 février dernier
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
avons devant nous des semaines encore
particulièrement difficile
plus que jamais les personnels soignants
dans le dévouement et la bravoure sont
admirables depuis 14 mois
mérite notre soutien et la
reconnaissance de la nation toute
entière
je me rends régulièrement dans les
hôpitaux pour leur manifester son
soutien
je sais car ils me le disent ce qu'ils
endurent
je sais combien ils se battent malgré la
fatigue malgré la lassitude pour sauver
des vies notre système hospitalier va
tenir le choc
nous l'y aideront en continuant de
mobiliser tous les leviers possibles en
déplafonnant les heures supplémentaires
dans les établissements de santé en
mobilisant tous les renforts possibles
en particulier les professionnels de
ville les retraités les étudiants santé
les 26000 professionnels inscrits à la
réserve sanitaire civile mais également
la réserve militaire en organisant la
collaboration entre le public et le
privé qui n'a jamais été aussi fluide en
organisant des évacuations sanitaires
depuis les régions les plus touchées
l'activation de l'ensemble de ces
leviers doit nous permet d' armée
jusqu'à dix mille deux cents lits de
réanimation et d'accueillir tous les
malades qui en auront besoin
mesdames et messieurs les députés face à
cette crise sans précédent et à la part
d'incertitude que comporte cette
épidémie
mon gouvernement agi avec cohérence et
pragmatisme
gérer une crise sanitaire gérer une
crise sanitaire s'est conjugué une
batterie de critères
il y a évidemment d'abord et en premier
lieu les critères épidémiologique et
sanitaire et donc oui les avis des
scientifiques et des médecins
je veux le dire et de répéter ici devant
la représentation nationale et devant la
nation toute entière
il n'y a pas d'opposition entre le
pouvoir politique et le pouvoir médical
nous tenons le plus grand compte des
avis des analyses des modèles et des
prévisions des experts conseils
scientifiques et médicaux mais et c'est
bien là le rôle du gouvernement
nous avons le devoir je dis bien le
devoir d' intégrer dans les prises de
décision d'autres considérations qui
relève de la dimension sociale scolaire
psychologique économique de notre pays
et de notre société
c'est là le rôle du politique ces
critères se modélise sûrement moins bien
et leur impact est sûrement moins
immédiat mais leurs effets sont un an
après le début de la pandémie
beaucoup mieux connu c'est dans la
combinaison difficile très difficile de
l'ensemble de ces critères que doit être
recherchée en permanence l' équilibre
des décisions qui nous appartient de
prendre c'est aussi cet équilibre qui
détermine la temporalité de ces
décisions mais au bout du bout et le
moment dans lequel nous nous trouvons
l'illustrent parfaitement la mer des
priorités le premier de ces critères
celui qui s'imposera toujours c'est la
protection sanitaire de nos concitoyens
comme toujours c'est dans l'unité et
dans le recours aux valeurs de
solidarité et de responsabilité que nous
trouverons les ressources pour faire
face à ce choc grave'
inédit c'est la caractéristique
profondes de cette crise mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires
elle fait appel au sens des
responsabilités
loin des postures facile loin du
simplisme au sens des responsabilités de
tous et de chacun et c'est dans cet
esprit comme toujours que je me suis
exprimée devant vous ce matin je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le président
olivier beige pour le groupe agir
ensemble et pour dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
ce matin pour voter sur les mesures qui
ont été annoncées hier soir par le
président de la république et que vous
avez à nouveau développé devant nous se
battent à monsieur le premier ministre
je le dirai d'entrée il ya le groupe
agir ensemble votera pour ces mesures et
cela au moins pour trois raisons la
première c'est que si ces mesures sont
durs elles sont durs particulièrement
dans ce week-end de pâques même si nous
sommes gré déjà de ne pas avoir confiné
le lapin de pâques ce qui est une bonne
chose
elles sont dures mais elles sont
nécessaires on ne peut pas faire
autrement face à l'évolution de
l'épidémie
deuxièmement la france est certainement
parmi tous les pays du monde occidental
celui qui a le mieux protéger le mieux
protéger ses citoyens et ses entreprises
la troisième raison c'est que le débat
que certains voudraient institut est ici
de dire qu'il aurait fallu confiné il ya
deux mois pour éviter de confie dès
aujourd'hui ou confinées aujourd'hui
pour éviter de confiner dans deux mois
ce débat n'a pas de sens il n'a pas de
sens car le but d'une nation n'est pas
de vivre confiner le but d'une nation et
de vivre normalement et si nous avons
des réserves a apporté sur la stratégie
viable c'est bien à ce niveau là qu'elle
se situe comme vous le savez le groupe
agir ensemble a proposé depuis plus de
six mois de ne pas simplement être dans
une stratégie de freinage mais être
également dans une stratégie
d'éradication du virus comme l'ont fait
les pays d'asie et d'océanie nitia en
testant massivement traçant et isolant
les personnes
positive avec une quarantaine aux
frontières force est de constater que ça
marche dans un certain nombre de pays
je cite les chiffres 10 morts à taïwan
35 au vietnam moins de trente également
en nouvelle zélande 900 en australie
c'est évidemment un bilan qui est assez
loin du nôtre
quand on regarde la stratégie de
freinage évidemment les effets de cette
stratégie de freinage et je le dis pour
notre pays mais c'est vrai pour toute
l'europe qui a adopté cette même
stratégique
les effets sont évidemment hautement
préoccupant préoccupant d'abord bien sûr
parce que nous avons bientôt cent mille
morts dans notre pays malgré des mesures
qui ont été prises préoccupant parce que
le système hospitalier et finalement
sous tension permanente depuis
maintenant un peu plus d'un an
préoccupant parce que aux morts du cog
hill il faudra ajouter certainement les
morts indirecte de toutes les
déprogrammations de soi que nous sommes
obligés de faire dans les hôpitaux
préoccupant bien sûr parce que de
nombreux secteurs sont aujourd'hui
encore à l'arrêt la restauration le
tourisme la culture l'événementiel
préoccupant parce que derrière ces
mesures ont un coût pour la nation qui
s'endettent de manière massive
évidemment à la charge des générations
futures
préoccupant aussi parce que derrière il
y à un risque de déclassement de
l'europe occidentale par rapport au
monde asie pacifique
une sorte de basculement de
l'accélération qui étaient déjà en route
et puis préoccupant aussi parce que
finalement à ne pas chercher à éradiquer
le virus et à le freiner
nous ne testons pas nos capacités
logistiques de résilience de la nation
et si nous devions demain être confronté
à un autre virus autrement plus mortelle
de type ebola ou autre eh bien nous ne
pourrions évidemment pas nous contenter
de simples mesures de freinage et ce
sont toutes les raisons pour lesquelles
le groupe agir ensemble appelé depuis
plusieurs mois pour que nous ne soyons
pas simplement dans une stratégie de
freinage du virus mais dans une
stratégie d'éradication qui nécessite de
mobiliser de grands moyens pour tester
massivement la population pour tracer et
pour isoler de manière stricte
évidemment les personnes positives et
les cas contacts en plus bien sûr des
quarantaines aux frontières qui sont je
voudrais souligner appliquée également
par d'autres pays aujourd'hui dans
l'union européenne en ce qui concerne et
les mesures que vous avez adopté et sur
lesquels nous nous prononcerons ce matin
nous l'avons dit ces mesures sont
nécessaires et elles sont nécessaires le
temps que notre système de soins puisse
à nouveau récupéré des capacités
d'accueil et que les taux de
reproduction du virus puissent baisser
incite les taux d'incidence
néanmoins il me semble important de
préparer d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui la
sortie de ce troisième confinement qui
n'en est pas un mais qui en est quand
même à quelque part ces mesures au
niveau du groupe agir ensemble nous
laisse où est ton de la manière suivante
la première chose nous souhaitons
évidemment l'accélération de la campagne
de vaccination mais vous je sais que
vous faites monsieur le premier ministre
avec votre gouvernement
tous les efforts nécessaires pour que
les français puissent être vaccinés
le plus rapidement possible ils sont
évidemment encore résoudre certains
problèmes logistiques
mais nous comptons sur vous nous pensons
qu'il faut également d'ores et déjà
accéléré à préparer les campagnes de
tests salivaires dans les écoles
lorsqu'elle réouvriront parce que c'est
indispensable pour éviter que les écoles
ne soient des lieux de reproduction du
virus
nous pensons également qu'il faut
s'interroger sur la stratégie vaccinale
pour les jeunes
nous avons un nouveau bac ça qui arrive
le vaccin johnson and johnson de vaccins
monodoses et nous sommes évidemment
préoccupés par la situation de tous les
jeunes qui doivent faire des stages cet
été pour valider leur master leurs
études parfois à l'étranger alors que la
condition vaccinale risquent d'être
imposés pour voyager dans certains pays
et nous pensons qu'il serait bien que
ces jeunes soient prioritaires notamment
ceux qui sont partis à la recherche d'un
emploi en fin d'études
et puis bien sûr il y a
l'ensemble des mesures qui seront
nécessaires pour réouvrir les secteurs
de la restauration de la culture du
sport
nous revenons sur des mesures que nous
avions déjà suggéré il ya de cela un peu
plus de 8 mois au niveau du groupe agir
ensemble équipes et notamment les
restaurants et les lieux claude qui
accueillent du public parfois hélas ce
sens sans masque puisque ce n'est pas
possible dans tous les lieux
faire en sorte que l'on puisse équipés
de manière massive ces lieux de systèmes
de recyclage rapide de l'air comme on
l'a dans les avions dans les trains qui
permettent de purifier et d'éviter ces
fameuses aérosols voilà si vous voulez
mes chers collègues les mesures que le
groupe agir ensemble souhaitent proposer
au gouvernement
nous le disons très solennellement nous
voterons évidemment pour ces mesures
parce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
nécessaires mais nous souhaitons
vraiment qu'il y à une évolution de la
stratégie sur ces différents points et
nous serons vigilants parce qu'il y aura
encore des lois d'urgence sanitaire à
voter et si à un moment ou un autre ne
sont pas au rendez vous également de ses
engagements et bien il n'est pas certain
que tous nos députés votent les
prochaines lois d'urgence sanitaire nous
préférons le dire aujourd'hui parce que
la situation est néanmoins préoccupante
pour notre nation
voilà il ne s'agit pas simplement
aujourd'hui ni jamais de mesures
techniques
il s'agit aussi de savoir ce que
l'histoire retiendra de cette crise
l'histoire c'est le personnage qui se
tient ici en bas à gauche de cette
tribune et sous le regard de laquelle
nous prenons ici nos décisions nous
avons pris des mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires
je ne sais pas qu'elle regarde
l'histoire aura sur les mesures que nous
prenons
je pense que l'histoire part d'hommes
souvent de ne pas réussir
rarement de ne pas essayer il ya nous
comptons sur vous monsieur le premier
ministre pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination pour éradiquer ce virus que
ce soit par la médication ou par les
mesures également dû tester tracé isolé
cela nous semble nécessaire aujourd'hui
pas simplement pour nos concitoyens mais
aussi pour l'avenir de notre pays
merci merci monsieur le président la
parole d'un monsieur pascal brindeau
pour le groupe des indépendants et pour
dix minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues en montant à cet instant
à la tribune je me suis posé la question
de savoir ce que je venais faire ici de
ce que nous venions faire ici et je me
disais que nous serions sans doute plus
utile dans nos circonscriptions auprès
de nos concitoyens parce qu'il faut bien
l'avouer monsieur le premier ministre
ça n'est pas un débat auquel vous nous
convier aujourd'hui de débat il ne peut
y en avoir il a suffi qu'un seul
prennent seules les décisions pour tous
viennent devant les plateaux de
télévision les annoncer et ces mesures
sont en voie d'être mise en oeuvre
d'ores et déjà donc de débat il n'y en a
pas et ça n'est pas vous faire injure
monsieur le premier ministre
de vous dire que vous êtes ici en
quelque sorte pour faire le service
après vente du président de la
république et que nous avons comme seul
rôle aujourd'hui de commenter ses
décisions et donc vous ne m'en voudrez
pas de ne pas commenter votre
déclaration
mais de commenter celle du président de
la république et je vais le site et
emmanuel macron hier dans son
intervention a dit nous avons gagné des
jours de liberté et nous avons bien fait
mais quel décalage mes chers collègues
qu'elle des connexions par rapport à ce
que vivent nos concitoyens depuis un an
pensez vous que les soignants se disent
aujourd'hui que nous avons bien fait de
gagner des jours de liberté qui voit une
nouvelle vague de submersion arriver
et sans doute que le seul la seule vertu
la seule utilité de nos discours de ce
matin c'est un nouveau de pouvoir leur
rendre hommage et de leur dire qu'aller
notre gratitude eux qui tiennent épuisé
depuis un an et qui ne voient pas plus
que nos concitoyens le bout du tunnel
aujourd'hui pensez vous que les salariés
qui ont dû bouleverser leur vie
professionnelle se disent nous avons
gagné des jours de liberté et nous avons
bien fait qui vont devoir encore
aujourd'hui et pour longtemps
bouleverser leur façon de travailler
pensez vous que les restaurateurs les
commerçants les acteurs de la culture se
disent nous avons gagné des jours de
liberté et nous avons bien fait eux qui
sont fermés depuis si longtemps à qui on
a dit ne vous inquiétez pas les mesures
qui vont être prises vont permettre de
ré ouvrir au plus vite
d'abord en avril puis en mai peut-être
demain en juin
à chaque nouvelle intervention
à chaque nouvelle intervention mes chers
collègues
ces perspectives qui sont indispensables
à nos concitoyens deviennent plus floue
je cite encore le président de la
république nous faisons face à une
nouvelle donne depuis les premiers jours
de mars avec un variant plus contagieux
et plus mortelle là encore quel décalage
avec la réalité
les épidémiologistes les chefs de
services des hôpitaux nous le disent
depuis janvier la situation des pays qui
nous entourent nous le montre également
nous savons que ce variant est plus
dangereux qui les plus mortels et qu'il
va plus vite en termes de contamination
et face à ce danger plus important
les mesures qui sont aujourd'hui prises
sont plus légères que celles qui ont été
prises jusqu'à présent avec le virus
souche
quelle est la cohérence sanitaire
aujourd'hui de ces décisions
comment pensez vous que nos concitoyens
vont réagir par rapport à ces nouvelles
restrictions qu'ils acceptent mais pour
qui les accepte et qu'il est exact c'est
pts d'autant mieux il faut qu'ils en
comprennent la cohérence en fait ce que
nous vivons ce sont les retards français
le président de la république de nouveau
a dit que nos capacités de lits de
réanimation serait porté à dix mille
c'est la troisième fois que ce chiffre
est annoncée qui devait être mise en
oeuvre après la première vague mise en
oeuvre après la deuxième vague
nous sommes à la troisième vague le
chiffre de dix mille lits de réanimation
en france n'est toujours pas atteint
comment voulez vous que nous vous
fassions confiance sur ce sujet alors je
les dis nos concitoyens dont je salue la
responsabilité et le courage sont prêts
à de nouveaux sacrifices
il le montre ils ont de la
responsabilité
ils ont du courage et c'est le signe de
la force de la nation française
mais ils sont près de nouveaux
sacrifices à une condition la clarté la
cohérence et la perspective
enfin d'en sortir et un an après un an
après rien n'a changé alors aujourd'hui
on nous propose un confinement qui
tantôt n'a pas dit son nom pour quatre
semaines
mais nous savons que dans 4 semaines
nous serons encore dans le pic ou au
moins dans un plateau haut de
contamination et c'est à ce moment là
qu'il est prévu de réouvrir les écoles
les écoles dont le président de la
république a dit hier qu'il n'était pas
un lieu de forte contamination alors que
celle inverse
nous le voyons à travers les chiffres
des ars les taux d'incidence sont
beaucoup plus haut chez les jeunes
générations maintenir les écoles
ouvertes a été une bonne chose
nous avons soutenu cette mesure mais où
nous avons dit aussi quand nous avons vu
les taux d'incidence augmenté dans ces
écoles qu'il aurait fallu prendre la
décision plus tôt de fermer ou
d'anticiper des vacances de manière
territorialisée ce que ne vous n'avez
pas voulu faire jusqu'à présent et
aujourd'hui vous êtes contraint après
avoir dit que vous maintiendrez des
écoles
quoi qu'il en coûte finalement de les
fermer la dureté de la crise sanitaire
nous éclaire aussi sur la réalité de la
crise politique et démocratique que nous
vivons nous souffrons en réalité en
france d'une trop grande verticalité des
décisions d'une suradministration de
leur mise en oeuvre depuis le début de
la crise monsieur le premier ministre
beaucoup sur ces bancs ont plaidé pour
des solutions territorialisée pour des
solutions adaptées plus dur là où le
virus sûr qu'il est plus plus légère et
plus respectueuse des libertés de nos
concitoyens là où ils circulent et - la
solitude des choix la confiscation du
débat
c'est ça aussi le mal français
en témoigne aujourd'hui ce débat qui
n'en est pas un en réalité c'est une
mascarade de débat auquel nous sommes
conviés mascarade auquel les députés du
groupe u10 et indépendants ne veulent
pas se laisser enfermer
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils ne
participeront pas au vote qui est prévue
à l'issue de ce débat
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'hubris grecque qui commande
aujourd'hui les choix d'un seul
c 'est tube rice qui a conduit icare à
se brûler les ailes merci monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur le
président bertrand prend cher pour le
groupe liberté et territoires et pour
dix minutes nous l'écoutons s'il vous
plaît sur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues depuis un an les français sont
éprouvés lourdement par cette crise
depuis un an ils subissent aussi
durement les conséquences de la gestion
de cette crise et avant toute chose je
veux leur rendre un hommage appuyé dans
leur immense majorité les françaises et
français ont fait preuve d'un grand sens
physique d'une patience à toute épreuve
ils ont accepté les limitations de leur
liberté sans broncher
ils prennent sur eux depuis maintenant
plus d'un an certains de nos concitoyens
nombreux sont en grande souffrance
je pense à cet instant à celles et ceux
qui ont eu la douleur de perdre un
proche parfois sans pouvoir faire leur
travail de deuil
je pense à celles et ceux qui gardent
les séquelles de la maladie depuis des
mois ce qu'on appelle maintenant les
qu'ovide long je pense aux larmes
versées combien de dépressions de france
est puisée de jeunesse perdue combien de
vies brisées
nous savons que les conséquences de
cette épidémie seront aussi
psychologique dans les traumatismes sont
profonds pour les commerçants fermaient
les acteurs de la culture de
l'événementiel pour les personnes âgées
isolées pour les étudiants je pense
aussi à ces hommes et femmes qui sont en
première ou deuxième ligne
les premiers de corvée personnels de
santé ehpad soit un domicile enseignants
fonctionnaires salariés mobilisés
agriculteurs pompiers je ne peux les
citer tous ils se reconnaîtront je veux
leur exprimer à nouveau notre gratitude
et notre confiance
c'est grâce à eux que notre pays a tenu
notons d'ailleurs que toutes les
déclarations pour améliorer la
reconnaissance parfois financière
de ces professions regard de leur
utilité collective tarde encore à se
concrétiser
eux aussi sont au bout du rouleau
combien de médecins d'infirmiers
d'aide-soignante ont quitté l'hôpital
abattus à bout de forces
je le disais les français monsieur le
premier ministre dans leur ensemble
subissent lourdement la crise et les
conséquences de sa gestion erratique
depuis un an nous avons une meilleure
connaissance de ce virus
des avancées scientifiques majeures ont
été accomplis même si la france est
restée en marge des grandes innovations
depuis un an
qu avez-vous réellement amélioré dans la
gestion de la crise depuis un an nous
n'avons cessé de vous alerter de
réclamer davantage de transparence
davantage d'anticipation davantage de
concertation à ce triangle vertueux vous
avez opposé le cercle vicieux
inconstance précipitations confusion
matinée d'autosatisfaction la mise en
scène des annonces du président hier
soir on est encore une triste
illustration
quel est le sens donné un débat
aujourd'hui au parlement dans l'urgence
alors que tout est déjà décidé d'en haut
est déjà annoncé quel sens donner au
vote qui suivra ce débat aucun aucun
loin de nous l'idée de minimiser
évidemment les difficultés d'exercer les
responsabilités les vôtres dans ce
contexte actuel lui gouverner en temps
de kobe des complexes
nous commençons à voir du recul sur
cette maladie des inconnues demeurent
sur les modes de transmission sur
l'apparition des variants mais plus les
décisions sont difficiles plus il faut
les faire partager
il y associer le plus grand nombre c'est
le contraire de ce que vous faites c'est
le contraire et si nous sommes en guerre
pourquoi ne pas avoir organisé l'union
nationale nous vous avions tendu la main
vous l'avez pas saisie vous faites le
choix opposé on écoute en personne ni
les scientifiques ni les corps
intermédiaires ni les enseignants ni les
parents d'élèves ni les élus locaux
évidemment ni les élus nationaux le
parlement lui est bafouée
on ne fera croire à personne que ce
débat vise à le réhabiliter le conseil
des ministres s'efface
seule demeure un conseil de défense
sanitaire qui ne laisse rien échapper et
un président seul et isolé
récemment le président déclaré aucun mea
culpa faire aucun remords aucun constat
d'échec
cette absence de remise en cause comment
ne pas la comparer avec l'attitude de la
chancelière allemande qui n'a pas hésité
à reconnaître des erreurs nos
concitoyens comprennent d'autant moins
vos manifestations d'autosatisfaction
qui l'ont heureusement de la mémoire
et encore ils se souviennent du déni sur
les masques
il n'oublie pas l'impréparation sur les
tests ils constatent les ratés du
déploiement de la stratégie vaccinale
nos concitoyens peuvent comprendre qu'il
y ait des tâtonnements qu'il y ait des
ajustements il les comprendre est
d'autant mieux si les décisions étaient
prises en toute transparence et avec
humilité transparence des indicateurs
notamment à l'est malgré nos demandes
elle fait cruellement défaut
ce matin sur le site du conseil
scientifique encore le dernier avis
consultables remonter au 11 mars
les français ont de la mémoire
heureusement revenons un instant sur les
décisions du 29 janvier dernier
ce jour là le président fait un pari au
mépris de l'avis du conseil scientifique
au risque d'une flambée de l'épidémie
fin mars nous y sommes
deux mois ont été perdus et combien de
vies perdues
combien de vies perdues j'entends le
chef de l'état se félicitait d'avoir
attendu le plus tard possible
ce choix je le dis avec gravité étaient
irresponsables irresponsable
le 1er mars le président déclare
imprudemment à nouveau qu'il faut tenir
encore quatre à six semaines avant un
premier assouplissement le pari là il
est aussi perdue et cela n'empêche pas
un nouveau confinement qui ne dit pas
son mot sur le moment et d'ailleurs
comment expliquer à nos concitoyens que
l'on repousse l'heure du couvre-feu
tout en instaurant un confinement d'un
genre nouveau
avec une attestation qu'ils ont sans
attestation et d'autres documents
illustration d'une techno d'une
technocratie en folie tout ceci nous
conduit donc à la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui marquée par un nouvel
emballement de l'épidémie
nos hôpitaux sont au bord de l'explosion
il nous savons que les deux prochaines
semaines seront terribles
à ce sujet une question combien de vies
de réanimation nouveau au réellement été
créés depuis un an
combien hier le président a évoqué une
course contre la montre
mais à ce jour là aujourd'hui c'est le
virus qui a gagné la course contre la
montre et s'en sont suivi les annonces
dévoilées hier dont vous assurez
maintenant monsieur le premier ministre
service après-vente semi confinement
désormais généralisé même dans les
territoires moins touchées
je ne reviendrai pas dans les détails
certaines mesures s'imposent et
notamment dans les écoles il faut
écouter les crânes des familles et le
monde enseignant
mais comment les familles vont-elles
concilier les semaines d'école à la
maison et le travail des parents est à
cet égard une pensée pour les femmes et
hommes qui élèvent seules leurs enfants
et pour les travailleurs non salariés
quelles sont les conditions de mise en
place des 2000 places déjà annoncé en
janvier elles tardent partout à
s'appliquer
comment concrètement améliorer les
protocoles sanitaires dans les
établissements l'aération des classes
par exemple réclamé depuis toujours demi
heure difficile qu'elle annonce sur la
vaccination des enseignants ils ne sont
toujours pas prioritaire dans le champ
économique et social nous avons entendu
que les dispositifs d aide aux acteurs
économiques seraient prolongées mais
qu'en est il pour les oublier pour les
jeunes pour les indépendants pour les
précaires
rien de neuf la réforme de l'assurance
chômage à elle elle est maintenue c'est
un scandale
rien de neuf non plus pour nombre de
salariés en télétravail seulement des
déclarations d'intention et
contrairement à ce que déclare elisabeth
bornes le télétravail n'est toujours pas
à ce jour une obligation
rien n'est dit non plus sur la tenue des
élections prévues en juin
nous leur disons que nous sommes
défavorables à confiner la démocratie
comme le président nous annoncer que
dans six semaines ça irait mieux et bas
donc il faut les maintenir
enfin un mot sur le déploiement de la
vaccination qui est la clé de la
réussite et de la sortie de la crise que
de rater et quelles différences de
perception entre les acteurs de terrain
que nous rencontrons tous les jours et
la haute administration
encore un exemple il y à 13 jours
monsieur le premier ministre vous
annonciez que la totalité des plus de 50
ans seraient vaccinés mi mai le conseil
scientifique lui estime à certaines la
tenue ce calendrier
hier le président confirmé d'ailleurs en
creux que cet objectif ne serait pas
tenue les obstacles sont les mêmes le
nombre de doses disponibles
la capacité à organiser la vaccination
efficacement et de manière coordonnée
aujourd'hui notre pays est affaibli
exsangue ses perspectives dans un avenir
proche sont floues mais n'en doutons pas
il se redressera ce pays se redressera
car il s'est toujours relevée grâce aux
françaises et aux français
pour ce faire il devra se réinventer
créer un nouveau modèle de développement
enfin humain par une démocratie plus
transparente plus aller coûte plus
vivante
notre pays doit s'y préparer et cela
passera par une organisation beaucoup
plus décentralisée agile moins
monolithique par une révolution
girondine c'est le choix inverse que
vous avez fait et dans lequel vous
persistez je les dis ce débat n'est
qu'une parodie le vote que vous nous
demandez est un vote de confiance alors
que vous avez créé les conditions de la
défiance
le parlement est un paillasson comme en
octobre dernier
nous faisons donc le choix de ne pas
participer à ce simulacre
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le président
jean luc mélenchon pour le groupe de la
france insoumise et pour dix minutes
ministre collègues
c'est vraiment 1er avril qu'aujourd'hui
et la blague du jour et cette mauvaise
mascarade
vous nous avez convoqué du jour pour le
lendemain que vous ne respectiez pas
l'assemblée est une chose mais permettez
nous au moins de respecter nos propres
groupes
impossible de se réunir impossible de
faire revenir tout le monde
impossible de se dédire des engagements
déjà pris cette réunion est une honte
pour le parlement français
elle ne sert à rien elle n'aura aucune
conséquence
tout est décidé et nous ne sommes
invités qu'à venir vous acclamer vous
vous en passerez le monarque
présidentiel meilleur virologue de
france paraît-il et meilleur ami de la
modestie est apparu hier soir à la
télévision et il a décidé au nom d'anne
ou qui pose problème à 100 nous de
majesté pour lui qui regrette le roi
hassan ou pour désigner le conseil de
défense dans lequel il ourdit en secret
ses plans et où tout se décide
peu importe le résultat sera le même
le président a tous décidé tout seul
tout annoncé hier soir à la télévision
et vous venez nous le répéter nous ne
pouvons rien amendé nous ne pouvons
voter que oui ou non rien amendé rien
proposer une nouvelle fois des onze
propositions de loi que nous avons fait
depuis le début de la crise des quatre
plans d'action de la commission des
requêtes
les innombrables amendements que nous
avons déposés voté ensemble avec nos
camarades commune
toi
le bot
n'aura aucune conséquence
car même si nous venions à voter non
tous unis pour une fois cela ne
changerait rien la responsabilité du
gouvernement n'est pas engagée par ce
vote
oui c'est un mauvais poisson d'avril est
le poisson d'avril comme tous les
poissons pourrit par la tête
les français par contre n'ont pas une
mémoire de poisson rouge eux
il se souvient que vous avez passez
votre temps à les tromper est le premier
jour le 23 janvier de l'année 2020 quand
madame busin déclaré le risque
d'introduction du virus en france est
faible sur les masques quand le premier
ministe déclaré le port du masque en
population générale
ça ne sert à rien le 19 mars 2020 il ne
servirait à rien de tester massivement
alors même que l'organisation mondiale
de la santé disait qu'il fallait
procéder de toute urgence et voulait
fauzy rien et puis alors le pompon le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
puisque sur l'école plus que tout vous
avez bafouillé trébuché à gardez vous
montrant plus habile à faire la chasse
politika l'islamo gauchisme coco vite 19
parmi les personnels et les enseigner
vous avez commencé par dire que le
danger n'existait pas pour les enfants
puis que ce danger existe et au point
qu'un seul malade par classe justifié
concerne séance tenante la classe puis
que ça pouvait être 3 il n'y a pas
besoin d'être très malin pour comprendre
que si 3 était malade tous les autres le
seraient bien vite ainsi que leurs
familles donc à trois on pouvait puis à
1 à nouveau et enfin aujourd'hui tout
est tellement parti dans le décor que
vous fermez toutes les grâces voilà où
nous en sommes
avec cet homme qui pour finir aura
représenté le principal danger à l'école
et qui est toujours là quoi qu'il ait
déclaré concis contaminé moins
qu'ailleurs le 22 janvier la commissure
la contamination reste limitée puis on
se contaminent mois à l'école caille
qu'ailleurs des malades par milliers des
centaines de classes fermées
des centaines de professeurs et d'agents
de tous métiers non remplacés et des
menaces par dessus le marché contre le
personnel récalcitrants mensonges à
répétition
roux est inacceptable comme ce 25 mars
2021 ou de nouveau emmanuel macron
khalid hull a dit qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'explosion prévu par tous les modèles
alors que précisément ces modèles
prévoyait l'explosion qui a eu lieu en
mars
alors ce jour de chiant lui est de trop
nous paye coteaux déjà votre comité de
suivi confidentielles
nous allons pratiquer un boycott du vote
un boycott d'exaspération nous refusons
de voter
nous ne sommes pas votre public vous et
à vous acclamer nous en avons assez de
voir l'assemblée exclus de la discussion
sur la stratégie à mettre en oeuvre
contre la pandémie nous à la brasse et
du mauvais suspense de ses déclarations
deux jours et deux nuits du président
qui parle souvent pour ne rien dire et
seulement pour se montrer
vous avez annulé la discussion prévue au
parlement en janvier dernier sur
l'organisation des stratégies sanitaires
face à la pandémie
pendant des mois à l'assemblée est
exclue de tout ce qui se décidait pas
consulté pour la mise en place du couvre
feu à 20h pas consulté pour l'as vence
du couvre-feu à 18h pas consultés sur la
décision de ne rien faire de plus en
janvier dernier pas consulté sur les
nouvelles mesures pour les 16
départements
vous nous demandez de voter uniquement
pour amnistier vos fautes
nous avons fait notre devoir de
parlementaire en vous alertant à chaque
étape sur la deuxième vague et la
nécessité de planifier le déconfinement
en mars 2020 vous avez ricaner nous vous
avons alerté sur la nécessité de lever
les brevets sur les vaccins nous l'avons
fait il ya un an et vous êtes toujours
rendu au même poids de voter contre dans
les réunions internationales tout en
signant de manière inepte et
irresponsable des tribunes dont vous ne
pensez pas un seul mot nous vous avons
alerté sur l'urgence d'organiser des
alternatives sérieuses au confinement
vous avait ricané nous vous avons alerté
sur le fait que le virus allait muté je
me suis fait prier pour la cause
sur la quatrième vague psychologique en
janvier dernier pareil ricanements et
vous le mans de tambours du garde
champêtre à intervalles réguliers
point final chaque fois ce furent
moqueries l'asie mépris et vous
continuez alors que vous êtes
responsable devant l'histoire d'un
désastre sanitaire comme la patrie n'en
a jamais connue
vous avez laissé la vague montée en
aggravant tout la dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
retire encore 800 millions du budget
d'économies pour les pital public à cet
instant délit continu être fermés vous
annoncer hier par la voix du président
dix mille lits et il faudrait pour se
battre les flancs de joie ça fait 4 plus
de moi qui la dernière annonce alors
lady apparaissent disparaissent
reviennent pas en fait vous ne pensez
pas un mot vous dire une chose et vous
faites le contraire et vous vous moquez
du monde
maintenant aucun recrutement de
professeurs ou d'assistants d'éducation
contrairement à l'italie qui on a
embauché 84000 aucun purificateurs d'air
ni dans la moindre salle de classe ni
même dans cet hémicycle
alors que cette machine existe qu'elle
est efficace et qu'elle est produite en
france
pas de mise à disposition des masques
ffp2 rien pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination et vous continuez à refuser
au nom de johnson & johnson & johnson le
vaccin russe qui lui a pas de nom il
s'appelle street mick comme le premier
satellite et j'ai vu que monsieur ciotti
disent est comme moi dorénavant
l'idéologie dans la crise sanitaire
c'est de l'obscurantisme et rien d'autre
rien fait pour organiser la société du
roulement
savez-vous dorénavant et depuis hier
soir
dans quel désarroi vous avez plongé des
milliers de familles qui avaient
organisé leur vacances qui doivent
dorénavant organiser leur présence à la
maison
non seulement pour maintenant mais dans
le moment où vous en verrez les plus
petits à l'école primaire tandis que les
plus grands resteront au collège
resteront à la maison
les gens ne savent plus de quel côté se
tourner ils savent par contre de leurs
droits au chômage vont être abattus ils
savent par contre que même avec le
chômage partiel
ça ne sera pas le total de la pauvre
paye avec la thielle déjà il n'arrivait
pas à faire face aux dépenses qui leur
sont imposées
j'avais vous que vous prétendez avoir
gagné du temps de liberté il n'ya que
vous pour croire que c'était un monde de
liberté que celui où tous les magasins
sont fermés et où à 18 heures il faut
rentrer à la maison coucouche panier
parce que sinon vous mettez indiciels
d'afrique comme un monde
on continue de fermer des lits
d'hôpitaux la liberté n'a été gagné que
par la production et l'accumulation nous
n'avons pas gagné du temps de liberté
nous avons perdu du temps de nettoyage
de l'air de vaccination la france
aujourd'hui comme toute l'europe à
confier son sort à une bureaucratie
misérable incapable d'organiser la
vaccination au point que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé vous reproche une
lenteur inacceptable jassem genre de
santé d'enseignement de culture chômeurs
vivre à la violence de votre récente
vous dit par ma voix est celle de mon
groupe
sa colère et son dégoût ne voteront pas
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à monsieur andré
chassaigne pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine et pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
chers collègues que faites vous de notre
république
cette convocation lendemain des annonces
du président de la république est la
marque du mépris le plus absolu du
monarque pour le parlement et à
l'endroit du peuple notre pays en est
désormais réduit à se plier aux oukases
d'un souverain trop content d'annoncer à
ses 66 millions de sujets le sort qui
leur réserve un souverain que rien ne
semble arrêter pas même ses propres
erreurs et les cris dallaire d'un
personnel soignant à bout de souffle
voter sur des mesures déjà annoncées at
il une quelconque signification
qui peut croire que l'application de
l'article 50-1 de notre constitution
n'est pas aujourd'hui un hochet tiré du
coffre à jouets pour faire comme si on
était en démocratie depuis un an notre
pays reste englué dans une crise
sanitaire qui semble sans fin des
territoires entiers sont abandonnés à
leur sort comme en outre mer ou en seine
saint denis depuis un an vous décider
seul sans tenir compte des avis et des
propositions de l'opposition
tout au plus ce fait vous mine de nous
vous nous informez quand tout est déjà
étalées à la une des médias
et comble du comble hier au soir le
président nous dira que ses décisions et
ses échecs sont le fruit de choix
collectifs alors qu'ils sont celui d'un
pilotage solitaire d'erreurs
d'appréciation et d'entêtement coupable
depuis le début de cette crise le
président de la république l'ensemble dû
gouvernement et la majorité ne cesse de
nous répéter avec une arrogance
désormais récurrent qu'ils ont raison
toujours raison qu'ils prennent les
meilleures décisions tandis que
s'accumulent des décès évitables
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour
commenter les nouvelles restrictions
annoncées par le président de la
république pour quatre semaines au moins
oui pour commenter il ya quelques quatre
semaines le même demandé aux français de
tenir encore quatre à six semaines
avant un assouplissement de ces
restrictions prises la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire était pourtant
prévisible à l'anticipation
vous avez préféré l'attentisme et une
gestion au fil de l'eau ce manque
d'anticipation nous retrouvons dans la
stratégie vaccinale la montée en charge
de la vaccination n'est toujours pas au
rendez vous mais à chaque effondrement
de preuves vous répondez par une salve
de promesses il ya 48 heures ici même le
ministre de la santé et paie six ans
jour après jour le mensonge osé affirmer
que nos voisins ne faisait pas mieux que
nous la vérité sic au regard du nombre
de doses administrées pour 100 personnes
la france se classe à la 21e place
est ce digne désigne de la cèze sixième
puissance économique du monde
alors que nous propose le président de
la république pour faire face à ce
désastre a son propre échec la fermeture
des crèches et des écoles pour trois
semaines et un mois pour les collèges et
lycées un effort de tous les soignants
alors que depuis un an ils sont à bout
de souffle et n'ont eu en échange que
droit à de belles paroles l'ouverture de
nouveaux lits de réanimation pour
atteindre l'objectif de 10 milles alors
que l'objectif depuis un an s'avérer
inatteignable la systématisation du
télétravail
alors qu'elle reste bon vouloir des
employeurs la fermeture de tous les
commerces dits non essentiels et cela
pour quoi
pourquoi parce que l'acte de foi du roi
soleil n'a pas suffi à briser la courbe
des contaminations
après l'épisode calamiteux des masques
et celui non moins funeste des tests
l'échec de votre stratégie vaccinale est
patente
alors que vous avez tout misé sur la
vaccination pour faire reculer le virus
que dire que dire des plus de 75 ans qui
aujourd'hui sont en cours dans
l'impossibilité d'avoir un rendez-vous
que dire que dire des commandes de
vaccins non encore honorées
que dire que dire de la farce des
vaccinodromes refusé plus ouvert voire
ouverte ou fermée
que dire que dire du retard à mobiliser
les capacités de production nationales
contre aux dires des vaccins
que dire du département de la seine
saint denis le plus touchés de moins
vacciner
que dire de l'annnonce de 220 mille
personnes vaccinées par jour car notre
voisin de l'est vaccine aujourd'hui un
million de personnes tous les jours
le constat c'est que depuis un an
notre pays n'a pas inclus ses capacités
hospitalières de manière pérenne
notamment en termes de lits de
réanimation avant l'épidémie cinq mille
à cinq mille cent et est ouvert en
france avec des taux d'occupation moyen
oscille entre 85 et 90 % au 19 mars la
direction générale de la santé a recensé
7500 3 dont 86% occupés par des patients
atteints par le core i do no en réalité
l'ouverture de ces lits ont impliqué des
déprogrammations d'opération avec toutes
les conséquences que l'on connaît
alain vers certains hôpitaux ont
continué à fermer des lits
d'hospitalisation
c'est une réalité résultat nous voilà
revenus à la situation d'il ya un an
les services de réanimation sont au bord
de la saturation et pour reprendre
l'expression d'un collectif de médecins
de l'ahp de l'ap-hp je les cite le
gouvernement se déresponsabilise de
façon hypocrite
quant aux écoles parlons-en des écoles
les annonces du président hier sont une
catastrophe pour tous nos enfants
vous avez jusque là laissé les écoles
ouvertes c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
non non pour satisfaire aux besoins du
medef et transformer les établissements
en garderie mais parce que nos enfants
en avait besoin
mais mais il fallait dans le même temps
mettre en place tout le nécessaire pour
empêcher leur fermeture
avez vous suffisamment protégé nos
enseignants non avez vous recruté du
personnel pour remplacer les absences
inévitable en temps de pandémie non
avez vous mis en place des classes
allégé pour éviter le développement des
foyers épidémiques non avez vous testé
largement pour éviter la propagation du
virus non
avez vous équiper les établissements de
purificateurs d'air non mais pire encore
monsieur le premier ministre vos annonce
s'accompagne d'aucune mesure
garantissant que les choses sont
désormais prises en mains et que nous
allons reprendre la main sur la
propagation d'épidémies
allons-nous profiter des fermetures des
écoles pour mettre en place un plan de
recrutement exceptionnel pour permettre
une réduction durable des effectifs
d'élèves dans chaque classe et le
remplacement des enseignants absents des
moyens supplémentaires vente il est
accordé à l'université pour accueillir
correctement les bacheliers de 2021 et
leur garantir une place à l'université
dans la formation de leur choix
la procédure parcours sup va-t-elle être
suspendu pour ne pas mettre en
concurrence des bacheliers qui n'ont pas
bénéficié des mêmes conditions d'études
avez vous annoncé que dès aujourd'hui
que la rentrée de septembre était
préparé nous savons déjà que non est ce
que vous allez garantie que pendant le
temps de la fermeture
les enseignants seront vaccinés équipés
pour se protéger que les locaux seront
équipés repensée sur le plan sanitaire
non est-ce que vous avez annoncé des
mesures concrètes pour accompagner les
enfants les plus fragiles et vulnérables
le temps des fermetures de classes nous
savons que non les travaux de la
condition d'en quête de notre collègue
marie george buffet ont montré combien
les effets du premier confinement on
était délétère sur les apprentissages de
nos enfants en particulier pour ceux
issus des milieux populaires
vous aviez l'obligation de vous soucier
de leur sort au même titre que celui des
enfants de soignants des travailleurs de
première ligne des enfants handicapés
les élèves décrocheurs et qui ne peuvent
pas suivre les enseignements à distance
depuis leur domicile doivent continuer
aussi d'aller à l'école pourquoi ne pas
demander par exemple aux opérateurs
téléphoniques
la gratuité de la 4g pendant toute la
durée de l'enseignement à distance pour
garantir à tous les enfants l'accès aux
outils numériques
il aurait été aussi de bonnes politiques
que de définir des règles nationales sur
l'enseignement à distance pour éviter
les inégalités selon les territoires et
les établis
monsieur le premier ministre nous en
sommes finalement au même point que l'an
dernier à la même date
vous nous faites les mêmes promesses de
sortie de crise
vous nous faites ces promesses sans
mesures concrètes pour en sortir
c'est l'annoncé hier soir est confirmée
aujourd'hui sont la conséquence de votre
improvisation est la conséquence d'une
conduite solitaire du pouvoir
vous nous mettez une fois encore devant
le fait accompli devant le fait accompli
de décision prise la veille pour le
lendemain de décisions prises sans
consultation démocratique préalable de
décisions prises sans préparation
les oppositions toutes les oppositions
voire plus vous ont fait des
propositions sérieuses des propositions
sérieuses qui aurait mérité d'être
étudiée qui aurait mérité d'être débattu
nous aurions pu bâtir collectivement une
sortie de crise à la hauteur voulait
continuer à décider seul
alors alors nous vous laisserons seuls
pour plébisciter les décisions déjà
prises
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur christophe castaner
présent castaner pour le groupe la
république en marche et profonde le nez
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les députés
au revoir monsieur mélenchon la
situation sanitaire s'aggrave à nouveau
le nombre de patients atteints de
lakovic 19 dans nos services de
ranimation continue de croître malgré
toutes les mesures mises en place le
nombre de contaminations reste très
élevé et dans nos services de
réanimation les passions souvent plus
jeunes souvent en meilleure santé arrive
de plus en plus nombreux et souvent pour
une longue durée
jour après jour nos soignants se battent
jour après jour nous vaccinons plus mais
jour après jour la vague de l'épidémie
continue de monter depuis plus d'un an
maintenant le virus de lakovic 19 a
changé nos vies nous savons le poids
qu'il fait peser sur nos soignants je
veux la rendre hommage
leur dire notre respect notre
reconnaissance
notre humilité aussi face à leurs
engagements
nous savons les efforts aussi que cette
épidémie impose aux français nous
représentons chacun et chacune d'entre
nous une parcelle de la république et
chacun sur les marchés dans les échanges
que nous avons dans les lettres que nous
recevons nous mesurons tous l'épuisement
de nos compatriotes mesureront leur
courage et leur volonté de résister
jusqu'à la dernière seconde à ce virus
nous savons bien alors qu'elle est la
complexité de la situation
quel est le besoin d' équilibre dans nos
décisions besoin d' équilibre entre la
protection de la santé
évidemment de tous de notre système de
soins de ce qui est et qui doit être et
demeurent notre principale priorité mais
d' équilibre aussi avec le moral des
français avec la préservation du
quotidien de notre pays
vivre avec le virus cela ne peut
signifier mettre notre vie en parenthèse
à chacune de ces secousses vivre avec le
virus c'est apprendre d'eux
et prendre au bon moment les décisions
les mieux adaptés pour le dompter
nous affrontons ensemble la pire crise
sanitaire depuis un siècle peut-être
même la pire crise depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale chaque pays
chaque pays a réagi pris des décisions
parfois hésité parfois réussi parfois
s'est trompé nous les premiers
certains en sont à leur quatrième
confinement tandis que d'autres qui
avaient cru au confinement préventif se
retrouve enfermé dans un confinement
sans fin
loin de moi loin de nous l'idée de les
blâmer car si une chose est certaine
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'existe aucune
solution miracle
alors bien sûr bien sûr en disant ces
mots j'entends déjà les rugissements de
ceux qui ont fait profession de
commentaire de la crise de toux ceux qui
se sont hâtés de critiquer pour être
bien certain de ne jamais jamais proposé
que je les envie que j'envie ceux qui
pensent la politique sont la
responsabilité leur âme le ram doit être
bien légères lorsqu'il s'agit de dire
tout et le lendemain son contraire vous
avez
ne criez pas monsieur le député il ya
bien longtemps que nous le savons mais
si le savoir médical monsieur le député
se mesurer aux décibels de vos cris vous
seriez un minima prix nobel de médecine
[Applaudissements]
vous savez monsieur le député que
j'envie la clarté des visions rétro
explique rétrospective que j'envie la
finesse de tous ces commentateurs du
passé rivalisant de pertinence et de
prédiction a posteriori que je jalouse
les héros d'opérette spécialistes des
plateaux télé qui s'affirme détenteur de
la pierre philosophale antivirus en
expliquant toujours après coup ce qui
aurait dû être fait hélas mesdames et
messieurs les députés
nous avons trop d'estimé pour les
français pour céder à ces facilités
nous pensons que nos mots ont un sens et
que nous pouvons éviter de dire blanc à
la tribune et noir sur les plateaux
depuis le début de l'année nous avons
fait un choix revendiqué celui de
freiner sans enfermer
nous nous sommes adaptés sans cesse aux
impératifs sanitaires sont jamais perdre
de vue leurs conséquences depuis le 16
janvier dernier
un couvre feu a été mis en place puis
des mesures de freinage dans certaines
villes nous ont fait le choix de ne pas
confiné sur des hypothèses tout en
prenant des décisions contraignantes
cette stratégie a permis de ralentir la
diffusion du virus
mais ne nous y trompons pas ce n'était
pas un pari
nous ne parions pas sur la vie des
français nous ne parions pas sur
l'avenir d'un pays
nous agissons nous assumons nous savons
la lassitude des français l'inquiétude
des entrepreneurs des commerçants des
salariés nous savons aussi le désespoir
des personnes endeuillées des proches
des personnes qui sont hospitalisées
nous connaissons la fatigue des
soignants les personnels mobilisés sans
discontinuer qui pourrait nier la
pression le stress l'inquiétude qui nous
touche et qui touchent chacune et chacun
d'entre nous saluons la patience le
civisme l'engagement de tous ceux qui
nous accompagnent au quotidien citoyens
d'abord soignons personnels des
administrations déconcentrées forces de
l'ordre et tous les autres tous ceux qui
sont en première ou en deuxième ligne
tous ceux qui permettent de tenir
ensemble
c'est l'intelligence de tous la
responsabilité la solidarité la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
de notre société qui nous permet de
tenir
nous traversons depuis plus d'un an dans
une crise sanitaire économique
internationale à laquelle nous résistons
ensemble à laquelle nous opposons tout
notre combativité unis il y a le temps
du débat politique il y à l'exigence les
critiques les critiques de nos
oppositions
je sais qu'elle ne manque pas
aujourd'hui mais je veux le dire ici
c'est sain et c'est légitime au 6 mai
battons-nous toujours dans la concorde
républicaine pour être à la hauteur de
nos responsabilités celles que nous ont
confié les français agissons avec calme
avec calme et raison bien sûr mais aussi
avec détermination et humanité toujours
notre stratégie évolue et s'adapte c'est
bien là sa force
chaque jour chaque heure le gouvernement
suit la situation et adapter les
dispositifs en lien avec la communauté
scientifique et les médecins chaque fois
qu'une mesure doit être prise elle et
elle est en tenant compte de tous les
impératifs et pas au rythme des émotions
ou d expression médiatique
il n'y a pas de cynisme il n'y a pas de
jeu pas de calcul
il y a la volonté de protéger les
français de les protéger complètement
depuis un an notre pays ce armes et
combat il ya un an une loi d'urgence
pour faire face à l'épidémie kovy 19 une
loi de finances rectificative été votée
en à peine quatre jours
elle donnait les moyens au gouvernement
et ses représentants de prendre les
mesures réglementaires forte pour
enrayer la propagation de lakovic 19 et
nous doter d'un arsenal exceptionnel
nous permettant de faire face à une
situation économique sociale et
sanitaire dramatiquement impacté par
l'épidémie depuis depuis le parlement a
pu examiner une dizaine de textes de loi
de nombreuses ordonnances ont été prises
je pourrais vous citer les lois
instaurant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
les projets permettant d'y revenir
je pourrais vous citer les nombreuses
lois de finances rectificative des
ordonnances
pourrais vous citer les centaines
d'heures de débats l'audition en
commission comme en séance
l'information et la transmission sans
délai des mesures prises au titre de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
car la crise que nous traversons appelle
plus que jamais un contrôle exigeant de
l'action de l'exécutif par le parlement
est à bien des égards le gouvernement ne
peut agir sans contrôle exigeant et
vigilant du parlement parce que les
mesures prises pour faire face à la
situation de notre pays affronte un
impact considérable sur le concitoyen
elle ne saurait relever du coût de la
seule volonté du pouvoir exécutif
et je crois je crois et j'en suis sûr
que depuis un an à l'assemblée nationale
nous avons été au rendez vous tout comme
d'ailleurs le gouvernement dans ce
domaine qui est un exercice de
démocratie et de transparence
j'entends j'entends les critiques
faciles
j'entends les fanatiques de la théorie
du complot qui font croire que le
conseil de défense dirigerait la france
dans le plus grand des secrets une
instance
madame la députée vieille de plusieurs
décennies qui permet au ministre de
demander l'avis de spécialistes serait
donc devenu du jour au lendemain
l'antichambre de l'autocratie ahurissant
ahurissant si on pareille crise aucun
conseil de défense ne s'était tenu et
c'est bien la corée réside le problème
mais la bonne foi importe peu à ceux qui
refusent d'affronter la crise pour
acculer un pouvoir qu'ils exècrent la
haine et la lâcheté sont mauvaises
conseillères surtout quand des vies sont
en jeu mais peu leur importe depuis ce
matin et à n'en pas douter dans les
minutes qui viennent deux orateurs et
des oratrices montrons ici à la tribune
pour se plaindre qu'aucun débat n'ait
jamais lieu ils le diront ici à la
tribune
triste paradoxe triste paradoxe qui
préfère l'image offert la forme au fond
et déploie des trésors de mauvaise foi
pour toujours toujours surtout éviter de
faire des propositions et parler du fond
ces effets de tribune ces effets de
tribune ou de plateau télé sont le
triste cache misère de la vacuité de
certaines propositions mais il ne mérite
ça va je vous le dis on s'attarde sur
ton cette crise a montré au contraire
que notre pays compte et du meilleur
je pense à nos soignants monsieur le
député le prix nobel de médecine
on ne l'a qu'une fois la deuxième année
on passe à côté s'il ne mérite pas que
pour ceux qui s'engagent
nous nous attendions sur cela je
voudrais penser à nos soignants à nos
soignants qui se battent méritent la
reconnaissance de nos applaudissements
comme celle de nos actes
le ségur de la santé portée par le
ministre de la santé des solidarités
olivier rang est un juste retour des
choses
19 milliards d'engagements concrets pour
15000 recrutement l'hôpital des nouveaux
matériels et une augmentation de salaire
sans précédent on parle d'environ 200
euros par mois pour une infirmière
à titre d'exemple et le parlement ne
pouvait passer à côté de cette remontée
en puissance de notre système de soins
et je suis fier que nous soyons à
l'origine d'une proposition de loi pour
favoriser la mise en oeuvre du ségur de
la santé je pense aussi dans ces héros
du quotidien à tous les français qui ont
respecté les mesures rivaliser de
solidarité je pense à nos élus et en
premier chef aux élus locaux qui ont
retroussé leurs manches pour aux côtés
de l'état accompagné nos concitoyens
faciliter la vaccination et être
toujours au côté des plus fragiles
d'entre nous je pense aux policiers aux
gendarmes à tous les personnels de la
sécurité civile mobilisée comme jamais
je pense enfin à notre étape qui bien
souvent un bouc émissaire facile
l'état s'est dressé de toute sa force à
soulever des montagnes a lancé en
quelques jours des dispositifs complexes
comme le chômage partiel et faire
respecter
du jour au lendemain des mesures fortes
et nouvelles je souhaite ici monsieur le
premier ministre a salué l'action des
préfets
qui ont été et je suis l'un des premiers
à le savoir sur le pont jour et nuit
ils ont agi sans cesse et se sont
adaptés sans compter pour que l'état
soit présent aux côtés de nos
concitoyens et des élus il y a un nom
face à la pénurie mondiale que certains
voudraient niais
l'urgence était de trouver de produire
des masques du gel hydroalcoolique pour
combattre ce virus inconnu il fallait
adapter des protocoles sanitaires il
fallait faire en sorte que les gestes
barrières soient connus et soit
respectée avec les français nous avons
gagné cette première bataille
nous n'en sommes plus là l'urgence porte
depuis le début de l'année sur le
déploiement de notre stratégie vaccinale
le 27 décembre dernier il y a trois mois
nous débutions une campagne vaccinale
oui oui nous avons été contraints par
les limites de la production mondiale de
vaccins les retards de laboratoire oui
nous aurions sans doute aimé commencer
plus vite voir plus grand
mais oui nous apprenons des erreurs et
nous réagissons aujourd'hui de la
pharmacie de quartier au stade le plus
grands tous sont mobilisés et l'on
vaccine dans des centaines de lieux
partout en france aujourd'hui nous avons
pris avec l'europe les mesures qui
s'imposaient et la production des
vaccins sur notre continent s'accélère
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure de
vacciner près de quatre cent mille
personnes par jour et nous allons
continuer à monter en puissance
notre objectif de la mi avril et d'avoir
vacciné 10 millions de français nous le
dépasserons est ce que cela suffit pour
autant est-ce que cela va assez vite
bien sûr que non mais n'oublions pas ce
que nous avons accompli
il a fallu sept jours or en janvier il y
un peu plus d'un an pour que la france
séquence le génome du virus
dix mois entre le premier patient connu
et l'agrément du premier vaccin là où il
aurait fallu pas mal d'années il ya
quelques temps
chaque vaccin est un pas de plus vers la
liberté d'ici quelques mois la pandémie
sera vexe vaincu grâce à
l'extraordinaire mots
utilisation scientifique technique
technologique industriel logistique
humaine public bien sûr mais aussi
privés mais je m'en venais d'être
provocateur et je ne voudrais pas la
dimension européenne et mondiale de
cette mobilisation pour ne pas provoquer
les nationalistes de tous crins noter
que ce sont souvent les mêmes qui ont
voulu semer le doute sur la réalité des
vaccins semer la graine complotistes
d'une dangerosité prétendu oui la france
a fait le choix de vacciner d'abord les
plus fragiles les plus âgés nous le
revendiquons nous n'avons pas mené cette
campagne de vaccination à l'aveuglé
c'est en vaccinant ceux qui ont le plus
de risques de contracter des formes
graves ou qui sont les plus exposés que
nous réduisons le plus le risque de
mortalité
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons vacciné près de 8,5
millions de français presque tous les
résidents des ehpad où la vie reprend 60
% des plus de 75 ans et bientôt un quart
des 65-74 ans surtout nous avons décidé
de mettre les bouchées doubles samedi
dernier la vaccination a été ouverte aux
personnes de plus de 70 ans partout sur
le territoire quel que soit leur état de
santé dans les prochains jours de
nouveaux centres de vaccination seront
ouverts partout en france
nous attendons l'arrivée massive de
vaccins dans les semaines et les mois à
venir
rien que ce mois ci nous devrions
recevoir plus de deux que depuis
décembre
monsieur le premier ministre l'objectif
de vaccination de 15 millions de
personnes d'ici la fin du premier
trimestre que vous avez fixé ici à cette
place au mois de décembre sera largement
dépassé en juin grâce à la mobilisation
des soignants grâce à la mobilisation
des pharmaciens des pompiers des
militaires et des élus près de la moitié
de la population française sera vaccinée
à la fin de l'été tous les adultes qui
le souhaitent devraient avoir pu être
vaccinés nous sommes en bonne voie de
remplir nos objectifs parce que la
vaccination est la mère des batailles
elle est notre espoir notre espoir de
retrouver une vie normale de ne plus
être contraints de nous déplacer de
travailler aujourd'hui cet espoir un
calendrier un calendrier concret un
calendrier atteignable
chaque collègue protéger vacciner c'est
notre manière de prendre le virus en
étau et de le jeter
d'ici quelques mois enfin aux oubliettes
du passé mais d'ici là nous avons encore
des combats à mener depuis un an notre
pays accompagnent toutes celles et tous
ceux qui subissent de plein fouet la
crise économique et sociale
le parlement a accompagné ces mesures
avec les quatre loi de finances
rectificative avec la loi de finances et
la loi de finances de sécurité sociale
pour 2021
il y a les jeunes bien sûr les jeunes
pour qui le plomb 2 7 milliards d'euros
1 jeunes une solution a été créé qui ont
bénéficié des aides spécifiques tels que
les repas au crous un euro notre
objectif apporter un soutien ponctuel
lorsque c'est nécessaire mais surtout
les accompagner vers l'emploi et vers
l'autonomie il y a les plus démunis
aussi ai je pense aux mesures de mise à
l'abri côté des prises et qui d'ailleurs
ont été salués par la cour des comptes
il ya enfin tous ceux qui subissent de
plein fouet les mesures de freinage du
virus sous la houlette du ministère du
travail et des ministères de l'économie
et des finances le dialogue social a été
plus intense que jamais il a permis de
mettre en place et maintenir le
mécanisme de chômage partiel et a permis
d'accompagner la médiation et le
rééchelonnement des crédits bancaires il
a permis d'aider au paiement des loyers
de faire des remises d'impôts directs et
de reporter les échéances de cotisation
nous avons mis en place des aides
conséquentes qui se sont adaptés à la
demande des entreprises
le fonds de solidarité permet la
compensation d'une part importante du
chiffres d'affaires des entreprises sans
prendre en compte bien sur les bénéfices
du click and collect une aide spécifique
pour prendre en charge les coûts fixes
elle a été créée et le prêt garanti par
l'état que nous connaissons tous je ne
reviendrai pas en détail sur les
dispositifs dead et de secours mis en
place mais je sais je sais comme
beaucoup d'entre vous pour avoir changé
au plus près du terrain
chez moi dans mes alpes de haute
provence avec de nombreux acteurs de
l'économie du tourisme de gestionnaires
de stations de ski ou de centres de
thermalisme des commerçants à quel point
l'accompagnement économique de l'état et
précieux indispensable tous tous nous
souhaiterions que la vie sociale
culturelle et économique reprenne son
cours mais tant que le virus sera là
l'accompagnement de l'etat sera là
également et notre groupe monsieur le
premier ministre y veillera enfin je
pense à nos écoliers nos collégiens aux
lycéens et aux étudiants aux enseignants
et à l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative
nous avons fait le choix contrairement à
d'autres pays de maintenir les écoles
ouverte le plus longtemps possible car
et le président chassaigne l'a rappelé
l'école est essentielle fondamentale
primordial c'est le bras armé de
l'égalité républicaine et nous en sommes
tous derrière jean michel blanquer
bien évidemment totalement convaincu
mais contrairement à d'autres pays et il
faut le souligner aussi ce choix de
maintenir les écoles ouverte le plus
longtemps possible ce choix a été gagnée
car l'école est essentielle elle est
fondamentale elle est primordiale c'est
le bras armé de l'égalité républicaine
c'est à l'école que les plus jeunes
peuvent apprendre c'est à l'école qui se
forme pour l'avenir qu'ils se forment un
avenir
notre obsession restera la même
évitez absolument les décrochages
préserver cette égalité à laquelle nous
tenons tant en adaptant le calendrier
scolaire nous restons sur ce chemin
d'équilibré
mes chers collègues oui nous devons
faire face à de nouvelles mesures
mais nous ne sommes pas résignés il ya à
près d'un an et quelques jours
aujourd'hui après l'allocution du
président de la république après
l'allocution du premier ministre j'ai
souvenir d'avoir pris la parole pour
annoncer les mesures prises pour lutter
contre la copie 19 ces mesures étaient
exigeantes contraignante éprouvante
nous ne savions pas jusqu'à quand cela
allait durer nous n'avions pas les
perspectives qui auraient pu nous
permettre de savoir quand cela allait
s'arrêter
nous ne savions qu'une seule chose c'est
qu'il fallait lutter unis aujourd'hui
notre chemin se dessine le président de
la république hier et vous aujourd'hui
monsieur le prémice avait fixé un cap
clair freiner plus d'abord avec des
mesures nationales supplémentaires et
une adaptation du calendrier scolaire
sans perdre un jour de classe renforcer
nos capacités de ranimation jusqu'à dix
mille lits ensuite en sonnant la
mobilisation générale
thaksin est vacciné sans cesse et sans
répit enfin la vaccination sera ouverte
aux plus de 60 ans dès la mi-avril aux
plus de 50 ans de la mi mai je veux
saluer aussi ici la décision de prendre
des mesures spécifiques pour la
vaccination des professionnels les plus
exposés
nous savons comment lutter contre le
virus et comment nous en sortirons nous
avons un horizon
nous devons tenir tenir pour enfin
pouvoir nous retrouver aujourd'hui
mesdames et messieurs les députés ne
laissons pas le virus ouvrir un second
front celui de la fracture de notre pays
la france fait face parce qu'elle est
uni la france s'en sortira parce qu'elle
fait bloc professionnels amis voisins
familles des enfants jusqu'aux grands
parents nous avons su montrer le visage
uni de la france exigent harassé mais
toujours mobilisés c'est ce qui fait
notre force c'est ce qui fait la france
c'est ce qui doit guider notre action
d'élu qui doit guider le gouvernement
avec les députés du groupe la république
en marche nous répondrons présents à
l'heure de la responsabilité
nous répondrons présents dans cette
dernière ligne droite à vos côtés
monsieur le premier ministre est aux
côtés du gouvernement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le président damien abad
pour le groupe l'est républicain pour 20
minutes
[Applaudissements]
le seul premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
antoine de rivarol disciple de voltaire
jugeant l'aveuglément de la haute
noblesse de son temps disait ils sont
toujours en retard d'une année d'une
armée d'une idée monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez avec le président de
la république toujours un temps une
vision et une décision de retard il y a
un an nous étions confinés car il n'y
avait pas assez de masques et de tests
il y a quatre mois nous étions confinés
car la promesse d'augmenter le nombre de
lits de réanimation n'avaient pas été
tenues aujourd'hui nous sommes à nouveau
confiné car la vaccination est lente et
chaotique
vous nous aviez promis de vacciner matin
midi et soir
mais en vérité vous nous confiner
printemps automne et hiver vous nous
aviez promis d'endiguer la première
vague mais en réalité vous ne fait que
subir la deuxième et encaisser la
troisième
vous nous aviez promis des doses de
vaccins pour tous dès cet été mais en
réalité vous ne fait que gérer la
pénurie de doses disponibles en reculant
toujours plus cette campagne de
vaccination de masse vous nous aviez
promis de gagner du temps face au virus
mais en réalité vous avez perdu du temps
et même du terrain dans la bataille
contre l'épidémie
vous nous aviez promis de la clarté de
la cohérence de la constance
mais en réalité vous n'avez fait que
naviguer à vue entre arrogance confusion
et virements et revirements vous alliez
promis même la stratégie de la tortue
française dépensant le lièvre américains
britanniques ou israéliens partis trop
vite selon vous mais en réalité vous
êtes enfermé dans la stratégie de
l'escargot se classant péniblement à la
50e place du classement mondial de la
vaccination
vous nous avez promis la confiance dans
les vaccins
mais en réalité vous avez installé la
défiance le doute la suspicion sur le
vaccin astrazeneca
vous nous aviez promis un plan de
réouverture pour les cafés hôtels
restaurants lieux de culture mais en
réalité vous êtes contraints de
barricader et fermer à nouveau à double
tour vous nous avez même promis un
retour à la vie normale à l'été 2000 21
mais en réalité vous nous faites un
retour à la case départ
ce nouveau confinement dont vous
préférez d'ailleurs taire le nom
c'est un ter repetita symbole de
l'arrogance aveugle au sein de laquelle
votre gouvernement et le président de la
république se sont enfermés comme si
vous aviez si peu appris de vos erreurs
passées n'oublions pas que si nous avons
re confiné en octobre c'est parce que
vous avez été incapable de tenir votre
promesse d'augmenter le nombre de lits
de réanimation venise de la santé
promettait pourtant quatorze mille lits
de réanimation en mars dernier
hier le président de la république nous
explique que l'ambition est désormais
ramenée à 7000 y un an un objectif
diviser par deux quel aveu d'échec
quel constat d'impuissance pour
l'ensemble de votre gouvernement
et quelle souffrance pour l'ensemble de
nos patients et de nos soignants sur le
ministre de la santé
où sont passés les lits promis dites
nous la vérité la vérité c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de lits supplémentaires et dans
certains territoires le nombre de lits a
même baissé
la vérité c'est que notre système de
santé n'a soutenu qu'au prix de
déprogrammation massif d'opérations dont
nous allons hélas payé un lourd tribut
on estime par exemple qu'il y aurait 13
mille morts du cancer de plus à cause de
ces des programmations
la vérité c'est que vous avez été
débordé par cette épidémie
et pourtant cette pandémie épidémie elle
n'est pas éternelle et nous ne voulons
pas être condamnée en revivre à
permanence stop-and-go délétère les
français n'en peuvent plus de ce
sempiternel jeu confine jeu des conflits
nés je reconfirme ce qu'ils veulent
c'est en finir avec cette crise
sanitaire
malheureusement nous avons compris que
la sortie de crise ne sera pas possible
avant la fin de l'été alors il c'est
vrai il faut le reconnaître le président
public manie l'art du en même temps
comme personne ici il parvient même à
nous annoncer hier une sortie de crise
sans calendrier de sortie de crise
1re confinement sans confinement des
écoles fermées sans fermeture des écoles
et même une vaccination sa vaccin
permettez moi de vous dire qu'il ya
vraiment de quoi en perdre son latin
pourtant
souvenez-vous le 1er mars dernier le
président de république demande aux
français de tenir je cite encore quatre
à six semaines
quatre semaines plus tard il vient au
contraire d'annoncer de nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires et un troisième
confinement désormais pour sortir de
cette crise sanitaire
il va falloir assumer vos échecs combler
le fossé abyssal entre vos promesses et
la réalité et arros arrêtez de vous
défausser de vos propres responsabilités
refusé d'endosser la responsabilité de
ses propres échecs tout en imposant
toujours plus de sacrifices aux français
ce n'est plus acceptable parce que ce
n'est pas la faute des soignants mais
celle de goût du gouvernement s'ils
n'ont pas été capables d'augmenter nos
lits de réanimation
ce n'est pas la faute des français mais
votre propre responsabilité si nous
sommes incapables de réaliser une action
de masse dès aujourd'hui au fond les
français vous demande qu'une seule chose
vacciner vacciner encore et l'acsi n'est
toujours
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est ce
que vous dites mais malheureusement ce
n'est pas ce que vous faites
hier encore quelques heures avant les
annonces présidentielles
le préfet de police de paris a annoncé
une baisse de 25% du nombre de vaccins
disponibles dans la capitale la semaine
prochaine aujourd'hui encore de ce
premier ministre au moment où vous étiez
en train de vous exprimer ici à la
tribune et de vous gargariser de votre
stratégie vaccinale l'om un slot ms
dénonce je cite la lenteur inacceptable
de la vaccination en france et en europe
la vérité la vérité c'est que le virus
avance plus vite que la vaccination et
que sans vaccins suffisant
le confinement sera toujours une voie
sans issue votre stratégie de
vaccination
ce n'est plus un pari perdu c'est une
verrine à sanitaires jusqu'à maintenant
nous connaissions la stratégie du en
même temps
désormais nous découvrons la stratégie
du à contretemps permanent et force est
de constater que depuis le début vous
avez constamment un temps de retard
cette stratégie du contretemps permanent
elle a un coût sanitaire économique
social et humain
vous nous manquiez un monde plus agile
et plus disruptif et on vous découvre en
réalité prisonniers des lenteurs
bureaucratiques et des lourdeurs
administratives
tétanisée par les conséquences
potentielles de vos décisions
le président de la république nous
explique que nous sommes en guerre mais
il a laissé les soignants les français
totalement désarmé manque de masques
bancs de test de gants de blues 2 /
blues de lire et animations manque de
kits de séquençage est désormais manque
de vaccins alors oui nous souhaitons que
ce nouveau confinement cerveau - à être
utile qui permettent de vacciner un
maximum de français et notamment ceux
qui sont en première ligne soignants
bien sûr mais aussi les enseignants et
l'ensemble des publics qui reçoivent du
public comme le demande
notre président christian jacob et comme
le préserve réclamé nicolas sarkozy nous
devons vacciner
eh oui matin midi et soir
la vaccination est notre seule porte de
sortie
c'est le seul moyen d'en finir avec ce
virus qui a endeuillé près de cent mille
familles françaises a dit je pense tout
particulièrement aujourd'hui et depuis
la fin du mois de janvier
ces vingt mille morts supplémentaires
c'est aussi bien sûr cette vaccination
le seul moyen de retrouver une vie
normale de tourner la page de cette
crise sanitaire qui éreinte les
soignants qui angoissent ces familles
qui inquiète les parents pour l'avenir
de leurs enfants y met à mal notre
économie et qui minent le moral des
français
sans une action une vaccination réussi
ce sont les soignants à qui je veux
encore une fois rendre hommage ici qui
encaisse de plein fouet cette reprise
les
et me sens une vaccination réussi c'est
l'éducation de nos enfants qui en pâtit
durement car ne nous y trompons pas ce
n'est pas seulement quinze jours de
fermeture de nos écoles collèges et
lycées
c'est malheureusement bien souvent une
année scolaire entière il s'en trouve
fragilisée sans une vaccination réussi
ce sont les restaurants les bars les
cinémas les boîtes de nuit les salles de
sport ils sont condamnés à rester
désespérément portes closes sans une
vaccination réussi ce sont les festivals
qui ne pourront pas se tenir cet été et
c'est la vie sportive culturelle
associative notre pays qui reste
durablement en travers hélas vous êtes
en train de rater complètement cette
vaccination des français
c'est une faillite sur les commandes sur
les acquisitions sur la production sur
l'acheminement sur la diffusion et même
sur l'exécution et comme cela ne
suffisait pas le président la république
a décidé le 15 mars dernier de suspendre
le vaccin astrazeneca 24 heures avant la
vie de l'om s 72 heures avant celui de
l'agencé européenne du médicament en
prenant une telle décision de supprimer
totalement prématurée vous avez redonné
du crédit aux antilles vax est rompu la
confiance des français dans ce vaccin
est bien sûr que c'est vrai et chaque
jour sur le terrain nous le constatons
nos médecins nos pharmaciens aux
infirmiers constate chaque jour des
annulations de rendez-vous vaccinaux un
peu partout quand le nom astrazeneca est
évoqué d'ailleurs le président la
république entretient un immense flou
sur cette avancée de la vaccination
il a inventé les rendez-vous vaccinaux
sandoz dès lors comment vous croire
quand vous n'avez de cesse de nous
annoncer une énième accélération de la
vaccination
comment vous croire quand vous nous
dites que nos voisins sont tous aussi
mauvais que nous dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
la grande-bretagne vaccine quatre fois
plus vite que nous quarante pour cent de
la population anglaise a déjà reçu une
première dose de vaccin contre seulement
10% pour la population française et elle
a même distribué des autotests aux
enseignants et aux élèves
contrairement nous en israël c'est 60%
de la population qui a déjà reçu sa
première dose et un vent de liberté on
commence à souffler
bah alors que tous les commerces bars
restaurants salles de sport et musées
ont rouvert l'allemagne bien que plus
peuplée que nous pleurs 20000 mort du co
vite de moins que nous et pourtant la
chancelière elle a eu le courage de
reconnaître ses erreurs et de présenter
ses excuses à la population
chez nous aucun mea culpa aucun doute
aucune excuse toujours de l'arrogance
est toujours de la fanfaronnade
cette arrogance elle nous a tant coûté
et pourtant depuis le début de la crise
nous avons fait systématiquement des
propositions toujours et encore
et vous allez voir vous n'allez pas être
déçu s'il est proposé dès le mois dès le
mois d'avril 2020 nous réclamions avec
les députés les républicains un
dépistage massif
vous nous avez dit à l'époque c'est
inutile avant d'entendre juin 2020 pour
multiplier les tests à grande échelle
deux mois de perdus en février dernier
nous demandions une harmonisation un
prolongement des vacances scolaires pour
ralentir la diffusion du virus dans les
classes vous venez simplement de le
proposer pour les vacances de pâques
là encore deux mois de perdu près de
3500 classes fermées du jour au
lendemain en raison de cas positifs des
textes et dès le mois d'avril 2020 avec
l'ensemble des députés
nous réclamions d'imposer le port du
masque obligatoire a minima dans les
transports publics et dans les lieux
clos
nous l'avons demandé dès le mois d'avril
2020 vous avez attendu le 20 juillet
trois mois de perdu trois mois de perdu
pour les français voilà nos propositions
et voilà vous retard par rapport à nos
propositions et continuons puisque vous
avez l'air dbsa continuons ensemble
pourquoi est-ce qu'en france que les
tests antigénique et les tests
salivaires ont mis le plus de temps à
être homologué
j'ai demandé avec notre groupe l'est
républicain
des tests salivaires partout dès le mois
de décembre dernier
vous avez attendu mars pour les déployer
dans les écoles
là encore trois mois de perdus en
janvier dernier nous avons demandé des
vaccinodromes à l'époque votre vise la
santé je disais au stylo vaccinodromes
avant que vous ne changez de pied en
jouant en avril là encore trois mois de
perdus dès le mois d'avril 2020 nous
demandions que les enseignants et les
élèves avec patrick hetzel soient
testées chaque semaine pour éviter que
le virus ne se propage à l'école je vous
avez attendu janvier dernier pour
annoncer un protocole de test à grande
échelle dans nos écoles neuf mois de
perdu et dès le mois de mars 2020 avec
eric ciotti et l'ensemble des députés
les républicains nous réclamions la
fermeture des frontières
pendant des semaines vous nous avez
rétorqué que c'était impossible et que
le virus n'avait pas de passeport avant
finalement de faire marche arrière et
d'accéder à notre requête le 30 janvier
dernier seulement 10 mois de perdus
monsieur le premier ministre dix mois de
trop dis-moi de lassitude
dis-moi d'épuisement dix mois pour rien
voilà si vous alliez suivi nos
propositions
la réalité que nous aurait pu affronter
cette crise sanitaire où nous dit vous
êtes dans l'opposition fait des
propositions mais je vais continuer
en juin dernier on a fait une
proposition de loi ici même et vous avez
refusé de voter notre proposition de loi
qui consistait à geler les fermetures de
lits et de services hospitaliers pour au
moins un an
la vérité il faut qu il faut qu'on se
dise les choses franchement
la vérité c'est que vous n'avez jamais
voulu nous écouter même si parfois vous
avez été contraint de reprendre avec
retard certaines de nos propositions
autant autant je le dis autant votre
gestion économique de la crise est
satisfaisante et globalement efficace
autant
attendez la chose autant autant votre
gestion sanitaire de la crise est
calamiteuse et poussive et à cette
gestion sanitaire à cette gestion
sanitaire chaotique monsieur le premier
ministre
n'ajoutons pas une crise démocratique je
vous ai entendu ce matin et nous le
disons clairement d'être l'ensemble des
députés les républicains la france ne
peut pas être le seul pays européen qui
mettrait sa démocratie entre parenthèses
alors maintenant le calendrier électoral
adaptons les modalités de vote et vivons
en démocratie
vivant avec le virus c'est une
responsabilité collective laquelle nous
devons bien entendu tous partagé
monsieur le président nous n'avons pas
vocation à endosser vos erreurs ni
validé cette gestion sanitaire
nous ne sommes pas comptable de vos
propres échecs sur les masques les tests
salivaires les lits de réanimation et
les vaccins alors vous demandez
aujourd'hui de voter sur des décisions
qui ont été prises hier
mais quel conseil municipal quel conseil
départemental et quel conseil régional
se permettrait de voter sur les
décisions qui ont déjà été adoptés qui
ont déjà été édictées voilà la réalité
la démocratie c'est la décision ici et
pas à côté parce que est donc très
clairement on ne participera pas à cette
mascarade démocratique et à ce simulacre
de consultation pour une raison très
simple c'est que mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement n'en vous
déplaise
ici nous sommes le parlement et le
parlement ce n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement ni une assemblée de
commentateurs spectatrice de ce qui se
dit et se décide à l'elysée ici on est
là pour voter la loi pas pour adouber la
parole jupitérienne d'un oracle à la
nation ou d'un épidémiologiste suprême
et si vous voulez engager la
responsabilité de votre gouvernement
et bien si vous voulez engager cette
responsabilité posez nous la question de
confiance et utiliser la quartier 49
de la constitution tels que la vème
république bon le permet non c'est
justement la responsabilité la
responsabilité du gouvernement devant le
parlement
le article 49 c'est le courage le 5-1
c'est l'armé des faibles c'est le
courage fuyons de gouvernement aux abois
et c'est la démocratie du vote inutile
puisque tout est déjà dans le marbre
mais ne changera que nous voterons pour
pourquoi rien ne changera
aujourd'hui alors oui dans ces
conditions nous n'avons pas à cautionner
cette parodie de démocratie
tout le monde l'a compris ici mais je
crois que tout le monde est en train de
le comprendre à l'extérieur et que nous
sommes pas là pour valider vos échecs
successifs
nous sommes là pour proposer une
stratégie de vaccination clair efficace
et transparente
tout simplement pour donner aux français
un nouvel horizon et non pas un mirage
de plus comme nous l'avons entendu hier
et ce matin
alors oui aux responsabilités nous ne
prendrons pas part au vote
en vous renvoyant avec l'ensemble des
oppositions à votre propre isolement et
en vous laissant assumer seule cette
bérézina sanitaire de votre politique
dans vous porter l'entière est l'unique
responsabilité
merci monsieur le président à bad
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le président
patrick mignola pour le mouvement
démocrate est démocrate apparenté pour
dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
sur le président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues presque au
terme de cette matinée au moment où nous
rentrons dans une période décisive celle
où nous devons prolonger encore les
efforts et les persévérance collective
nous devons nous rappeler que c'est
aussi un moment une période où des
familles sont en deuil où de nombreux
autres sont dans l'inquiétude et je
crois que le temps sans porter de
jugement sur les uns et les autres et
probablement un peu plus à la gravité
dans la tonalité de nos propos que
nombre d'entre ceux que j'ai pu entendre
et au fond il faut choisir la politique
plutôt que la polémique et la
responsabilité plutôt que la théâtralité
alors le groupe que j'ai l'honneur de
présider dans ce moment décisif que nous
vivons vous dira pourquoi nous allons
soutenir les mesures que vous avez
présenté va formuler des propositions
pour rendre le mois qui vient les
semaines qui viennent
utile et juste et je vais m'efforcer de
dessiner quelques chemins d'avenir
je reviens d'un mot sur la question
institutionnelle puisque nombre d'entre
nous parmi les oppositions ont annoncé
ne pas vouloir participer à ce scrutin
j'ai l'honneur de présider un groupe qui
est très attaché à la séparation des
pouvoirs et à leur équilibre et je crois
que nous sommes exactement dans ce que
prévoit la constitution du général de
gaulle c'est à dire qu' un gouvernement
qui décide qui présente des mesures qui
fait face à la crise et un parlement
qu'on interroge qui doit discuter qui
doit commenter qui doit donner son avis
qui doit formuler des propositions et
qui doit à la fin adopter ou rejeter et
je crois que nous faisons face à un faux
procès et peut-être même une petite
habiletés de la part d opposition qui ne
voudrait pas dans les temps que nous
vivons étalé leurs divisions entre ceux
qui sont systématiquement opposée et
ceux qui auraient pu être
pragmatiquement constructif moi je dis
que quand on est en responsabilité au
vote ont choisi et on vote
et moi je mets au défi les oppositions
dans cet hémicycle vous avez été élu
pour voter et pas pour déserter surtout
dans les temps que nous vivons
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas nous voterons et nous
voterons en faveur de ces mesures et je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que ces
mesures sont chers collègues ils ne font
pas de crier parce qu'elle arrive au bon
moment
d'abord elles sont claires les tiennent
en deux phases pour protéger nos anciens
dont le mois qui vient
on va s'occuper de nos enfants vous
pouvez tout dire mes chers collègues à
droite plutôt qu'à gauche dès lors ils
sont plus calmes pouvait tout dire mes
chers collègues mais pensez juste aux
français qui aujourd'hui sont dans
l'inquiétude
juste ça de arrêtons de donner une image
indigne de la représentation nationale
indigne de la politique
mettons nous au niveau soyons là où les
français nous attendent nous pouvons
être en désaccord
vous avez renoncé à l'union nationale
très bien soyons en désaccord assumant
ses désaccords mais ne désertons pas la
responsabilité et surtout c'est son
d'étaler ses mots ces violences
[Musique]
nous en tout cas dans cette majorité
nous choisissons de dire sur le chemin
que nous allons vivre
les mesures sont claires qu elles sont
carrées qu elles sont courageuses et
qu'elle arrive comme lady d'ailleurs ce
matin la présidente de la région ile de
france sur les antennes le président de
la république a eu raison de ne pas
confiné en février
ces mesures supplémentaires de freinage
arrive au bon moment et s'il en fallait
une preuve
parce qu'on peut prétendre à la tribune
de l'assemblée nationale il faut
apporter les preuves s'il en fallait une
preuve
j'ai peut-être un tropisme savoyard mais
regardons nos voisins transalpins qui le
jour même où le président de la
république en france a choisi de ne pas
confiné ont choisi eux de confiner en
suis très ouvert et dans la semaine où
nous décidons de mesures supplémentaires
ont pris exactement les mêmes mesures
donc oui ce temps a bien été un temps de
liberté gagnée d'apprentissage
supplémentaires et il faut le
reconnaître nous pouvons être fiers
d'avoir fait confiance à nos concitoyens
parce que si nous n'avions pas fait
confiance à nos concitoyens quelles
auraient été les alternatives
l'infantilisation est plutôt qu'un fanti
lisez nos concitoyens nous avons choisi
la responsabilité et la confiance alors
comment rendre la plus utile et la plus
juste possible
la période qui s'ouvre
on formule d'abord une première
proposition parce que évidemment que
nous allons rentrer dans un temps où
tous ceux qui peuvent télétravail et
doivent le faire on doit se l'imposé et
je veux saluer ici à l'assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs le travail qui sous
l'impulsion du président ferrand avait
été confié à notre collègue wasserman
que nous avons adoptée à l'unanimité
pour que nous puissions nous aussi des
matières ya lisez notre travail mais
tout le monde ne peut pas télétravail et
il ya des français plus exposés que
d'autres et il ya un an ces français là
deux premières lignes de deuxième ligne
nous leur adressons des applaudissements
moi je pense que il faut aller
aujourd'hui au delà des applaudissements
et et dans les remerciements et des
remerciements plus sonnants et
trébuchants des gratifications et au
fond à travers des primes à travers la
bonification du compte épargne temps ou
de contrer par une retraite monsieur le
premier ministre je crois que dans le
secteur public en partenariat avec les
collectivités territoriales qui souvent
au printemps et à l'été dernier avait
choisi de procéder à ces gratifications
mais également dans le secteur privé
grâce à la prime macron que nous avons
remise en oeuvre que nous avons prolongé
je pense qu'il est important puisque
nous savons aujourd'hui à travers les
documents uniques à travers les critères
de pénibilité
ceux qui sont les plus exposés je crois
que dans le temps qui vient nous devons
les saluer les accompagner et les
récompenses et c'est une première
proposition du point de vue de la
vaccination d'ailleurs vous avez bien
fait de choisir de travailler dans le
dans l'ordre en fixant des priorités est
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre de la
santé c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il y a moins
de tension et moins d'entrées dans les
services de réanimation pour les plus
âgés dans notre pays et pour les plus
fragiles et pour les plus comme morbide
adoptons la même démarche de
priorisation pour que les français les
plus exposés
je pense un certain nombre de personnels
publics aux enseignants évidemment à
celles et ceux dont nous avions observé
le travail et le courage
quand il travaillait en deuxième ligne
au printemps dernier pour que ceci
lorsque l'âge sera venu soient
prioritaires à la vaccination
il faut que l'esprit de justice continue
d'accompagner cette stratégie vaccinale
et puis parmi ces français les plus
exposés exactement collègues jumelles il
y aura aussi les assesseurs
puisque vous nous demanderez sans doute
au début du mois de juin prochain de
prolonger l'état d'urgence sanitaire
comme nous l'avions réclamaient
d'ailleurs que nous soyons régulièrement
interrogé sur la prolongation de cet
état d'urgence et compte tenu de la
situation
il sera nécessaire de le voter mais
prolonger l'état d'urgence au début du
mois de juin les élections devant se
tenir le 13 et 20 juin suivant il
convient je crois que nous interrogions
les maires se sait pas seulement les
grands élus qui doivent décider
nous avons pris connaissance évidemment
avec attention de du rapport du conseil
scientifique qui ne nous a pas enfermer
dans la témérité de ces préconisations
mais qui en revanche nous a plutôt
impressionné par la densité des
conditions préalables à la tenue des
élections
si les élections doivent donc se tenir
en juin sous la pression d'un certain
nombre de présidents de région qui
voudraient expédié le sujet pour passer
à autre chose
on le regrette beaucoup parce que les
élections locales sont des élections
importantes pour nous qui avons été
longtemps élus locaux dans les temps qui
viennent nous avons besoin des régions
sur le plan économique sur le plan de
l'aménagement du territoire sur le plan
de l'urgence climatique et je ne crois
pas qu'il faudrait expédié ce scrutin
mais si tel devait être le cas alors
consulté les maires on peut pas être
dans une vie politique ou tout groupe et
tous bancs confondus
on répète le mot territoire toutes les
deux phrases et ne pas les interroger
lorsqu'ils seront eux aussi en première
ligne ce sont eux se sont pas nous qui
allons décider la tenue des élections
il s'agit d'un double scrutin il faudra
vacciner les assesseurs
au fond si à la fin nous prenions la
décision de mettre ces élections à
octobre plutôt qui a joint la démocratie
française n'en serais pas
stabilisé et nous ne mettrions pas en
compétition des français les uns avec
les autres dans la stratégie vaccinale
alors monsieur le premier ministre chers
collègues
il nous reste quelques semaines pour
travailler pour permettre aux françaises
et aux français de retrouver d'ici le
mois de mai d'ici le mois de juin d'ici
cet été
une vie d'après qui sera pas tout à fait
celle d'avant ou de nouvelles
solidarités se seront construites
moi je pense nous pensons avec le groupe
démocrate que la vie d'après ce sera la
vie d'avant mais en un peu mieux merci
monsieur le président la parole est un
malade à madame la présidente valérie
rabault pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés pour dix minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
pas un mot de compassion du président de
la république hier soir pour les 95
mille six cent soixante sept personnes
qui sont mortes
ducobu dans notre pays
pas un mot pour les quatre cent mille
personnes qui ont été hospitalisées ou
qui le sont encore
pas un mot pour les 4,6 millions de nos
concitoyens qui ont été infectés par le
coronavirus pas un mot pour celles et
ceux qui subissent encore les effets du
co vie de long aussi c'est à elle et à
eux et à tous leurs proches que je
voudrais penser en cet instant présider
la france l'a gouverné
ce n'est jamais s'abstenir d'empathie
pour les français présider la france et
la gouverner c'est partager le destin
nos concitoyens et donc s'associer aussi
aux blessures qu'ils subissent
aujourd'hui vous venez devant le
parlement pour aborder le troisième
confinement je dis bien confinement à
partir du moment où l'on ferme les
écoles et l'on demande aux français de
rester chez eux cela s'appelle un
confinement
ni le président de la république ni vous
monsieur le premier ministre avait
prononcé ce mot comme si depuis le début
vous cherchez à ne pas nommer une
réalité que nous subissons en somme pour
ne pas l'affronter
aujourd'hui vous venez devant le
parlement pour détailler ce que le
président de la république a déjà
annoncé hier soir or monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre a
été dit
le parlement n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement de décisions prises
ailleurs le parlement est le lieu où la
décision se fait et où elle est votée
après une délibération un débat
transparent et démocratique
mais depuis le début de cette crise le
président de la république semble
vouloir faire de la santé publique
l'un de ces domaines réservés ce qui est
contraire à la constitution
avec le débat de ce jour vous voudriez
nous faire avaliser cette situation nous
prenait tu mens nous ne participerons
pas à cette mascarade
nous ne prendrons pas part au vote sur
votre déclaration
si vous aviez choisi de mettre votre
responsabilité en jeu nous l'aurions
fait nous aurions voter ne pas prendre
part au vote c'est aussi vous dire que
nous ne pouvons cautionner la manière
avec laquelle vous gérer cette crise
bien sûr la situation est d'une
incroyable complexité et aucune réponse
évidente n'existe mais c'est justement
parce qu'elle est complexe qu'elle
devrait vous inciter à une réflexion
partagée
sincèrement le président de la
république pense t'il être plus
intelligent que la chancellière
allemande qui prend la peine de débattre
sept heures durant avec les présidents
de région pour élaborer un consensus qui
prend la peine de faire voter toutes ses
décisions par le bundestag et qui
déplorent aujourd'hui vingt mille morts
de moins que nous alors que l'allemagne
compte 17 millions d'habitants de plus
pourquoi nos élus qui font fonctionner
la république du quotidien les maires
les présidents de conseils
départementaux ou deux régions sont ils
si peu associé à vos décisions
alors que depuis cette crise il pallie
les nombreuses carences de l'état ne pas
prendre part au vote aujourd'hui c'est
souligner votre irresponsabilité face à
la science et je pèse mes mots
monsieur le premier ministre le 28
janvier j'ai été horrifié
je vous le dit horrifié par les
projections vous avez glissé dans votre
présentation à la page 16 très
exactement
d'ailleurs je ne vous ai questionnés que
là dessus depuis ses projections
m'obsède
je dois bien l'avouer parce que je sais
qu'elle montrait que nous allions dans
le mur
désormais il est trop tard et le mur
nous sommes en train de nous le prendre
le 18 mars ces projections avait disparu
de votre présentation
comme s'il ne fallait pas montrer
qu'elle était en train malheureusement
de se réaliser
alors non vous ne pouvez pas dire que
l'augmentation actuelle des
contaminations et subite et imprévus le
président de la république ne peut pas
dire comme il l'a fait hier soir nous
sommes entrés dans une nouvelle course
de vitesse tout ceci était clairement
prédit dans les projections janvier et
vous avez sciemment décidé de ne pas en
tenir compte
la réalité est qu'aujourd'hui la france
est le cinquième pays de l'union
européenne avec le plus fort taux
d'incidence après l'estonie la pologne
la hongrie et la république tchèque ne
pas prendre part au vote aujourd'hui
c'est vous dire que nous ne croyons plus
à vos annonces comment leur accorder du
crédit quand aucune de vos annonces
précédentes de ces réalisé le 3 décembre
dernier vous annonciez que 15 millions
de personnes seraient vaccinés avant le
printemps monsieur le premier ministre
pas à la fin du second pas à la fin du
premier semestre
le printemps c'est fin mars comme chacun
sait le printemps c'est fin mars
fin mars nous y sommes huit millions de
personnes sont vaccinées ou une première
dose quand vous en aviez annoncé 15
millions
le 1er mars le président de la
république parlait pourtant de tenir je
le cite quatre à six semaines avant que
ça aille mieux
le 3 mars le porte parole du
gouvernement déclaré qu'on retrouverait
une vie je le sais
plus normal dès la mi-avril en réalité
la seule chose que nous retrouverons en
avril c'est le confinement version 3
dernier exemple au début de l'année vous
avez annoncé un million de tests dans
l'éducation nationale pour le mois de
janvier
personne n'a vu la couleur ne pas
prendre part au vote c'est vous redire
que nous ne comprenons pas que vous
n'ayez pas mis en place une organisation
commando pour la vaccination
parce que la vaccination c'est la seule
bonne nouvelle de l'année 2020 et
qu'elle fonctionne dès 9 juillet 2020
dans un environnement au gouvernement le
conseil scientifique pressé le
gouvernement d'établir une stratégie
vaccinale nationale et proposer une
série de recommandations en ce sens le
13 octobre mon corps et mon collègue
boris vallot était premier parlementaire
a interrogé le gouvernement sur sa
stratégie vaccinale réponse du ministre
de la santé
rassurez vous tout est en cours de
préparation sur ce sujet comment être
rassurés quand nous avons vu début
novembre que plusieurs pays ont lancé
l'organisation de centres de vaccination
et que dans le nôtre
rien n'était prêt alors bien sûr il ya
des retards de livraison des doses et
elle touche et il touche tous les pays
européens mais pourquoi avoir attendu
début mars pour ouvrir la vaccination
week-end pourquoi avoir attendu la mi
mars pour lancer une campagne de
vaccination sur laquelle vous dites sans
cesse accéléré résultat les courses en
france 13% 13% de la population a reçu
au moins une dose contre près de plus de
30% aux etats-unis où 90% de la
population aura accès à un vaccin à
partir du 19 avril
nous en sommes tellement loin dès lors
comment voulez vous que nous croyons
président de la république quand il
annonce que d'ici la fin de l'été tous
les français de plus de 18 ans qui le
souhaitent pourront être vaccinés
comment le croire
ne pas prendre part au vote s'est
dénoncé la situation dans les services
de réanimation depuis un an rien n'a
changé et nous en sommes au même point
que l'an dernier
pas une nouvelle place de réanimation
n'a été créés alors même que la deuxième
vague était pressenti dès le 14 juillet
en réalité rien ou si peu à changer pour
l'hôpital ou plutôt si la situation
s'est dégradée
le personnel soignant est désormais à
bout et je voudrais lui rendre hommage
ne pas prendre part au vote c'est ne pas
accepter ce que vous faites subir à
l'école je ne reviendrai pas sur le
million de tests annoncé en janvier qui
n'a jamais été réalisé au delà de leur
non réalisation
il est extrêmement choquant que vous
demandiez une participation financière
aux enseignants pour les tests
salivaires
concernant la continuité pédagogique les
enseignants vont devoir reprendre les
cours à distance pendant au moins une
semaine
mais les difficultés d'accès aux outils
numériques chez les enseignants comme
chez les élèves demeurent le 9 juin
c'est-à-dire il ya dix mois maintenant
dans notre plan d'orgon nous avions
proposé au gouvernement de reprendre le
plan numérique à l'école qui avait été
lancé ce précédent quinquennat que vous
avez interrompu et qui permettait de
permet de qui permettait à chaque élève
de disposer d'un support numérique pour
profiter de contenus pédagogiques
innovants vous vous êtes contentés de
verser une prime informatique de 150
euros aux enseignants mais qui ne peut
raisonnablement pas financer l'achat de
l'ensemble du système d'informatique la
jeunesse va inéluctablement et encore
une fois payé le prix fort de ce
troisième confinement certaines mesures
prises récemment vont dans le bon sens
et nous avons tout de suite soutenu
leurs pains euros pour les étudiants et
les chèques ce psy mais elle reste très
insuffisante face à l'ampleur de la
crise qui frappe la jeunesse mais ne pas
prendre part au vote
si vous dire aussi ce que sont nos
exigences celles qui ne figure pas dans
votre déclaration
d'abord la vaccination des enseignants
il y a deux semaines monsieur le premier
ministre nous vous l'avions déjà demandé
alors je vous le redemande encore une
fois aujourd'hui proposer à tout le
personnel éducatif qui le souhaitent
d'être vaccinés avant la reprise des
cours en présentiel soit le 26 avril
soit le 3 mai ensuite pour les
réanimations nous voulons le détail des
déprogrammations que vous mettrez en
oeuvre pour espérer libérer les 5000
places qui ont été annoncés hier soir
cela va forcément se faire au prix de la
santé d'autres concitoyens des hôpitaux
nous vous demandons donc de nous
indiquer comment vous allez créer 5000
places nouvelles en trois semaines
troisième demande nous voulons
voir chaque semaine une comparaison du
nombre de nouvelles contaminations et
celle de la projection qui avait été
établi le 28 janvier quatrième demande
pour les jeunes la mise en place d'un
revenu minimum d'un revenu jeunesse
immédiate
pendant toute la durée de la période
sanitaires enfin pour la production de
vaccins
nous voulons à court terme la
publication de votre plan de production
par cip par type de coopération avec les
industriels au delà vous devez soutenir
la levée des brevets est considéré le
vaccin comme un bien commun universel
monsieur le premier ministre quand on
prive nos concitoyens de leur liberté
comme c'est le cas depuis un an
la contrepartie est une exigence de
résultats je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole
comme madame marine le pen pour cinq
minutes
j'espère que c'est pas moi qui vous fait
fuir merci monsieur le président et le
premier ministre le meschers collègues
la période d'incertitude sanitaires que
nous vivons pardon que nous subissons
depuis plus d'un an mérite mieux que
l'intervention d'hier d' emmanuel macron
entre 2 mai à cuba de circonstance la
vague promesse d'un calendrier quelque
peu élastique ou l'énumération des
conditions de rendez-vous de vaccination
le président de la république avait pour
l'occasion endosser le costume d'un
fonctionnaire d'une ars pour les esprits
logique
cette intervention qui réflète le
maladif équilibre du en même temps a
ouvert davantage de questions qu'elle
n'a apporté de réponse
comment se fait-il que lorsqu'on parle
d'une maladie la question des
traitements que certains pays
prescrivant kit soit purement et
simplement évacué de tous propos publics
comment comprendre la fermeture des
commerces de proximité c'est à dire en
pratique leur ruine
lorsqu'un rapport de l'institut pasteur
le rapport fontanet nous confirme
expressément qu'ils ne sont absolument
pas des lieux de contamination
pourquoi avoir cédé au confinement
indifférenciée dans la territoriale
isation à laquelle le président semblait
s'être converti permettait de laisser
respirer les zones épargnées cas garanti
d' accélération du calendrier de
vaccination pouvons nous attendre d'un
pouvoir qui sous-tend le choix des
vaccins ses lubies idéologique à des à
priori absurde qui produit par exemple
des valses un russe ou chinois lorsque
les allemands ou les italiens y ont
recours emmanuel macron a d'abord
cherché à rassurer
rassuré sur la prise de conscience des
erreurs commises rassurer sur les
retards accumulés ou rassurer encore sur
les perspective d'une sortie de crise
que lui même c'est en l'état
hypothétique dans une situation qui
tourne au chaos sanitaires et
économiques
le pays a davantage besoin d'être
conduit que d'être ingénument rassurer
le semblant de canossa politique d'un
homme exerçant la pluie
fonctions tout comme ça plus glorieuses
résignation à une simple gestion de la
pénurie ne font pas une politique et
encore moins au beau milieu d'une crise
nationale majeure une stratégie la
politique est l'art de rendre possible
le nécessaire professeur richelieu l'un
des plus grands hommes d'état qu'est
connu la france
force est de constater que perdu dans
les méandres bruxelles loi est perclus
par les blocages administratifs bien
français qu'ils n'ont pas su lever le
dirigeant donne le sentiment qui devient
exaspérant de chercher toujours à gagner
du temps peu de conviction et beaucoup
d'indécision
voilà ce que nous avons ressenti en
l'écoutant selon moi deux principes
doivent s'imposer
premièrement s'il doit y avoir
confinement c'est avant tout celui des
malades
à défaut le confinement territorialisée
doit être privilégiée deuxièmement la
lutte contre la pandémie doit être menée
par tous les moyens techniques
scientifiques et humain à notre
disposition
à côté des gestes barrières qui reposent
plus largement sur la responsabilité des
comportements individuels à côté de la
mise en place de protocoles sanitaires
dont personne ne méconnaît la nécessité
à côté des contrôles aux frontières qui
doivent être en effet enfin effectif les
autorités doivent agir dans quatre
directions prioritaire le dépistage
individuel par les tests pcr bien sûr
mais aussi les autotests qui doivent
être disponibles partout pour sécuriser
davantage les citoyens
par exemple lors des réunions de famille
même réduite et le dépistage collective
avec le repérage des clusters par
l'analyse des eaux usées le traitement
et leur corollaire qu'est la liberté de
prescription médicale j'aurais voulu
entendre l'annoncé d'un soutien massif à
notre recherche et à notre industrie
pour mettre enfin au point des
traitements
le moratoire immédiat est impératif sur
les réductions des capacités
hospitalières sur tout le pays et la
réouverture immédiate des hôpitaux
récemment fermé comme le val de grâce
parce que nous avons le devoir d'éviter
les décès différés liés
des programmations nous devons disposer
au plus vite des 12000 places que
monsieur véran avait promise au pays en
juillet dernier enfin une stratégie
vaccinale française doit suppléer sans
attendre au fiasco bruxellois l'om est
celle même dénonce inacceptable lenteur
de la vaccination en europe alors
diversifions nos sources
d'approvisionnement de vaccins et
développons enfin une production
nationale
l'objectif est naturellement de vacciner
l'ensemble des français qui le
souhaitent au plus vite les chiffres
donnés triomphalement ce matin par le
premier ministre étant très très mauvais
il doit aussi être antiste dont il est
il doit être aussi d'anticiper les
besoins éventuels ultérieure liées à
l'apparition de nouveaux variants ou
d'une altération dans le temps de
l'immunité collective
j'ai noté dans l'intervention du chef de
l'état cette phrase nous ne dépendrons
pas des autres et ça mea culpa à propos
jeter au vent une révélation du seul le
sait je ne peux que partager cette
phrase car elle fonde une grande partie
de mon engagement politique
une phrase pour ceux qui savent qu'un
peuple n'est jamais bien défendu que par
lui même une phrase qui pourrait être
celle d'un homme libre il décidé de nous
délivrer de ses errements idéologiques
celle d'un homme d'état s'il décide est
sur toute autre considération de
privilégier l'intérêt national
merci madame la députée la parole est à
monsieur olivier verront ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés mais ce premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres d'abord je voulais remercier
évidemment chaque parlementaire qui
s'est exprimé ce matin quel que soit le
contenu de son expression parce que je
crois que ce débat est important à
l'heure à laquelle nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui des questions ont été posées
et je voudrais pouvoir y répondre sur le
champ sanitaire
d'abord sur la question hospitalière et
j'entends souvent cette question et je
la comprends
vous nous avez dit que vous montreriez
attend de lits de réanimation pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'y en a quelques 8000 qui
sont ouverts aujourd'hui et pas
davantage il faut que vraiment chacun
puisse saisir cet enjeu parce qu'il est
il est fondamental ce que nous voulons
c'est qu'il y ait toujours des places
libres en réanimation pour accueillir
les patients qui relève de la réunion de
la réanimation au moment où ils en ont
besoin
nous ne sommes pas dans une logique de
tri nous ne serons jamais dans une
logique de tri et pour cela nous
adaptons l'hôpital qui est puissamment
moderne est capable de cette adaptation
comme il l'a fait depuis plus d'un an au
pic de la première vague
nous sommes montés à dix mille cinq
cents lits de réanimation et nous
serions montés encore davantage s'il
avait fallu le faire comprenez une chose
c'est que pour augmenter les lits de
réanimation pour augmenter les vides
réanimation nous devrons d'abord rouvrir
des unités ou ouvrir de nouvelles unités
ce que nous allons faire par exemple à
paris ou à l'hôpital henri mondor des
unités de speed de réanimation ont été
ouvertes pendant la première vague
nous allons ouvrir de nouvelles unités
qui n'ont jamais été ouverte en y
adjoignant du personnel soignant issus
de la réserve sanitaire des étudiants
des retraités 60 nouveaux lits sont
attendus à mandeure 320 10 au total
de plus dans les hôpitaux parisiens ça
c'est une donnée qui est extrêmement
importante
deuxième façon d'augmenter les lits de
réanimation elle est plus péjorative
hélas il s'agit de libérer débit qui
aurait pu être nécessaire pour d'autres
patients n'étant pas atteints d'une
copie d' or on a besoin de lits de
réanimation quand on a été opéré parfois
c'est une prothèse de hanche
parfois c'est une intervention cardiaque
parfois ce sont des pathologies
chroniques qui peuvent se des compensées
et donc la déprogrammation
nous l'utilisons
avec raison avec parcimonie lorsqu'elle
est devenue absolument nécessaire une
question était posée sur le niveau de
déprogrammation nous sommes par exemple
en ile de france
au delà des 40 % de déprogrammation des
soins c'est à dire ce sont des soins qui
sont reportés qui ne sont pas annulés
mais qui sont reportés et qu'ils peuvent
il faut dire les choses être une perte
de chance malgré tout pour un certain
nombre de patients qui ont besoin de se
faire opérer parce qu'ils ont mal quand
ils ont de l'arthrose ou parce qu'ils
relèvent d'une intervention chirurgicale
qui va être différée de quelques
semaines vous imaginez bien que si nous
montions du jour au lendemain a dit me
lit de réanimation
ça voudrait dire que nous des programmes
aurions d'un seul coup 80% des soins
programmés dans notre pays alors même
que nous avons sept mille cinq cents
patients aujourd'hui en réa avoir 2000
ou 3000 lits de réanimation vide en
attendant qu'ils soient remplies ne sert
à rien c'est même dangereux
en revanche se dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle y est pris il ya un autre lit
qui se libère pour accueillir un autre
malade c'est la bonne façon de
fonctionner et c'est ce que font les
soignants c'est ce qu'ont fait les
hôpitaux
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
n'imaginez pas je suis sûr parlementaire
vous en avez des courriers de
réanimateurs d'infirmiers qui le dit
mais pourquoi vous dites qu'il faut
augmenter tout de suite du jour au
lendemain dit billy vous rendez pas
compte de ce que c'est dans notre
quotidien du soir présent comme travail
ce que je vous dis c'est qu'au moment où
nous aurons besoin est hélas nous
devrions avoir besoin hélas d'avoir ces
quelques dix mille lits et quelques de
réanimation au moment où ils en auront
besoin
nous les aurons est ce là est
l'essentiel
notre chaussure l'hôpital c'est la
capacité d'évacuer sanitairement des
patients dans la situation sanitaire est
stabilisé mais qui sont en coma intubé
et ventilé des patients lourds de
libérer des lits là où il en a vraiment
besoin dans l'urgence en évacuant des
patients vers d'autres territoires
plus de mille évacuations sanitaires ont
été faites dans notre pays et ce sont
des vies qui sont sauvées et des
patients qui ont pu être soignées dans
de bonnes conditions
et donc ces évacuations sanitaires
doivent reprendre partout où elles sont
nécessaires sur tout le territoire
national des déprogrammations ont été
faites justement pour libérer de la
place pour accueillir notamment des
patients franciliens ou issus des hauts
de france de la même manière que la
région ile-de-france a été amenés à
accueillir des patients études d'autres
régions pendant la première et la
deuxième vague
et puis ensuite il ya la question du
structurel pas du conjoncturel dans la
crise dans l'urgence d'une structure nc
quel avenir
quelle vision pour l'hôpital de demain
cette vision ça a été dit par le trident
castaner c'est celle du ségur et
finalement c'est la vision du ségur
c'est celle des soignants hospitalier je
vais vous donner un exemple dans le cas
du ségur investissement vous savez nous
reprenons de la dette nous investisseurs
nous investissons façon majeure dans
l'hôpital et nous changeons le regard
sur l'hôpital l'hôpital de nancy
le chu de nancy était un projet qui
était budgété validé accepté contester
un peu localement mais globalement
acceptée j'ai souhaité que nous ouvrions
ce dossier nancy sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
et nous avons dit non seulement nous
nous nous allons financer votre projet
mais nous allons rajouter 120 millions
d'euros de financement pour que vous ne
soyez pas budgétairement trop serré et
grâce à ça qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vous deviez supprimer 200 lits on
arrête les suppressions de lits on va
pas les supprimer et non seulement les
supprime pas mais on va ouvrir en plus
60 lits de rééducation
grâce à ce budget on leur a dit vous
aviez encore 300 postes de soignants à
supprimer vous les supprimez pas aucune
suppression de postes alors qu'il en
avait 300 qui était encore une fois
planifier et avec ce budget on leur a
dit on vous demande de faire moins
d'administratifs et plus de soin il ya
150 postes administratifs qui sont
transformés en postes de soins c'est ça
la donne qui change c'est ça le ségur
concrètement pour les soignants et
semaine après semaine je serai amené à
décliner territoire par territoire
des projets comme celui-ci avec plus de
lits plus de soignants plus de place
pour avoir un hôpital plus fort mais
évidemment que cela prend du temps et
tous ceux qui ont exercé le pouvoir
savent très bien qu'on ne font pas un
réanimateur
en trois mois il faut plus de temps pour
former un réanimateur que pour former un
ingénieur qui va construire une fusée
qui va sur mars
deuxième grande salve de questions qui
ont été posées c'est sur la vaccination
et tout le monde a souligné
et ça c'est une première réjouissance ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas dans une
histoire contemporaine de notre pays
mais toutes les personnes qui sont
intervenues ont souligné l'importance de
la vaccination pour sortir de cette
crise nous partageons le même objectif
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous partageons le même objectif
vacciner
et bien de quoi parlons nous est-ce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un problème
logistique dans la vaccination de deux
pays
la réponse est non monsieur le député y
at il un centre de vaccination qui
ferment faute de vaccinateurs
y at il un sens qui va pas de bras pour
pouvoir accéder y at il un centre qui
dit qu'il n'est pas capable d'utiliser
les doses qui lui sont données y at il
un sens qui dit qu'il n'a pas les
capacités de fonctionner normalement
y at il un médecin y at il un pharmacien
qui vous dis moi je n'arrive pas
utiliser d'eau les doses dont je non non
ce que disent les élus ce que disent les
directeurs de centres ce que disent les
médecins les autres
firmi et les pharmaciens et le ministre
c'est que nous voulons plus de doses
pour vacciner davantage la population
c'est ça la question la question n'est
pas logistique
regardons une seconde la comparaison je
veux pardon pour la question je me
contrefous de savoir s'il ya trois pays
où cinq pays où huit pays qui ont plus
vaccinée la question c'est que faisons
nous des doses qui lui sont attribués
aujourd'hui la france
on est à touche à touche encore une fois
ça n'a pas de sens mais on est passé
devant l'allemagne devant l'italie
devant l'espagne sur vous ce qui
parraine un retard après cinq jours de
vaccination au début janvier voit
aujourd'hui que non seulement il n'y a
pas de retard mais qu'en plus nous avons
les patients les plus âgés vaccinés que
92 % des résidents en dépassant protégés
et que la mortalité baisse de notre pays
grâce à la vaccination
là où elle continue d'augmenter dans
certains pays qui ont démarré peut-être
cinq jours plus tôt mais qui ont vacciné
au tout venant sans prioriser les
personnes les plus fragiles
nous allons continuer avec
cette vaccination par ordre de priorité
nous allions y intégrer des publics
prioritaires de par leur profession des
enseignants les forces de sécurité
progressivement quand ça fait sens
c'est-à-dire lorsque nous aurons été
capable avec les doses que nous recevons
de vacciner prioritairement les
personnes qui hier année en réanimation
hier décédé et qui aujourd'hui ne sont
plus contaminées par le virus
elle est là notre victoire collective
pourquoi est-ce que troisième salve de
questions qui ont été posées pourquoi
est ce que vous prenez des mesures
maintenant si vous aviez confiné fin
janvier on ne serait pas obligé de
confiner et qu'est ce qui se passe avec
les projections des scientifiques etc
je comprends parfaitement la question
d'abord je voulais vous dire que fin
janvier mais il y avait en janvier même
y avait les prévisions des modélisations
qui montraient qu'ils allaient y avoir
une vague fortes liées aux variants
anglais sud africain et brésil
l'état de droit constitutionnel cette
constitution faite par le général de
gaulle
messieurs dames réparti les pouvoirs les
attributions
pas de lait 2020 il est beaucoup plus
nation parce que c'est effectivement
notre porte de sortie et vous le savez
et vous le savez toutes et tous
je vous avais mesdames et messieurs les
députés et je salue
e
[Applaudissements]
le le débat est clos nous allons nous
allons procéder au scrutin en
application de l'article 65 du règlement
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que le vote se déroulerait dans les
salles voisines de la salle des séances
je fais annoncé le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
le scrutin est ouvert pour 30 minutes il
sera donc clos à 12h30
la séance est suspendue